So los geht's, hi Leute, zumindest an die, die schon da sind.
Ich werde heute probieren Akimbo Pistole frei zu spielen, weil ich will das unbedingt noch
ausprobieren, bevor die Beta vorbei ist. Ich habe mal vorher nachgeguckt, ich habe keine
genaue Uhrzeit gefunden, wann die Beta vorbei ist, deswegen vermute ich mal wahrscheinlich heute Nacht
irgendwann oder so. Also ich werde das Game definitiv nicht pre-ordern jetzt, garantiert
nicht. Und wenn wir heute wieder so viele Hacker treffen wie gestern, schon mal erst gar nicht.
Auch schon voll die Schwitzer gefunden. Meinst du Leute, die sich anstrengen damit? Weil dazu habe
ich meine ganz eigene Meinung zum Thema Schwitzer. Also was wir gestern in Massen gefunden haben,
sind irgendwelche Hacker, beziehungsweise Leute, die sich halt irgendwo ein X22 oder so gekauft
haben. Leute, die sich anstrengen, klar, habe ich auch schon einige gefunden, aber ich bin der
Meinung, jeder der sich nicht anstrengt in einem Multiplayer-Spiel ist eigentlich ganz schön doof.
Also ich finde das Wort Schwitzer ist quasi so, ist irgendwie so voll fail und an dem Sinn
eigentlich vorbei. Weil warum sollte ich mich nicht anstrengen, wenn ich ein Multiplayer-Spiel spiele?
Wo es darum geht, gegen andere Leute zu spielen. Das kann eigentlich nur von Leuten kommen,
die quasi Easy-Penta-Nuke machen wollen. Ja, Larin, das ist das gleiche, Tryhard und Schwitzer.
Schwitzer ist quasi das deutsche Wort für Tryhard. Von Leuten, die wahrscheinlich nicht mal wussten,
dass es Tryhard heißt. So, warte mal, welche Klasse hatte ich denn jetzt hier eigentlich für
meine Pistole gemacht? Die hier? Die hier? Moment. Two Attachments on Secondary Weapon. Ja, aber für
Pistole brauchen wir ja eigentlich eher Fireguns, weil es Printing. Also wir müssen erst mal
frei spielen, Pistole. Wir haben für die Pistole noch nichts. Machen wir mal hier. Was haben wir denn für das Ding?
Haben wir da irgendwas Gescheites? Okay, also Leute, die Games werden jetzt wahrscheinlich ziemlich kacke.
Ich muss jetzt nämlich für die Pistole, ich muss die Pistole hochleveln.
Manche chillen einfach gerne beim Zocken. Können sie machen, spricht ja keiner. Es muss sich ja
keiner wirklich anstrengen, wenn er nicht will. Aber wenn jemand will, dann zu sagen, das ist ein
Schwitzer oder so, finde ich irgendwie so voll am Sinn vorbei. Ich finde es vollkommen legitim,
wenn man sich anstrengt, wenn man ein Multiplayer-Spiel spielt. So, das denke ich halt zum Thema Schwitz.
Ich finde auch Tryhard und so ist halt klar. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise, wenn ich
Overwatch ranked spiele, dann tryharde ich auch und für mich ist das überhaupt nichts Negatives,
sondern ich würde mir wünschen, dass zumindest Leute, die ranked spielen, standardmäßig tryharden.
Ja, Heisenberg, das stimmt schon. Dann hat man eher, da hat man aber ein ganz schönes Problem,
wenn man wirklich auf Tryhards Freaks spielt, weil Call of Duty ist so random. Sagt mir mal,
ob es zu laut ist. Ich glaube, ich habe es ein bisschen zu laut. Ja, Moment, ich muss ein bisschen,
ich mache ein Tickenleiser. Hoffentlich überlebt das Spiel das Reintappen. Input lag, Input lag,
Perfekt, Input lag, Input lag. Oh, die Performance ist mal wieder scheiße. Die wechselt immer.
Ah, jetzt, jetzt. Okay, jetzt haben wir wieder 100, 200 FPS, easy. Was? Ich sage euch,
wie gesagt, die Gameplays waren richtig kacke jetzt. Ich muss Pistole leveln. Wer hat mich
da gekillt? Ich hoffe, die Pistole levelt auch, wenn man keine Leute killt. Wisst ihr,
das Level Waffen nach Damage, nach Hits oder nur, oder nur nach Kills, weil dann dauert es ewig.
Ja, Heisenberg-Krampffakt, also eine gewisse Entspannung beim Spiel muss schon dabei sein.
Und man spielt ja auch besser, wenn man quasi vorbereitet ist und ein bisschen entspannt ist.
Also, es ist einfach so, die besten Spielzüge macht man in der Regel, wenn man sich in der
Situation befindet, die man halt geübt hat, wo man halt einfach weiß, was man am besten
jetzt machen muss. Und klar, vor allem wenn es ranked ist, manchmal ist halt Tryhard angesagt,
da kann man nichts machen, das muss so sein. Och Gott, ey, wie scheiße die Pistole ist.
Ich dachte aber, auf Wack kann man nicht cheaten, klar. Guckt ihr mal an, wie voll CSGO mit irgendwelchen
Cheatern ist. Nicht zu sagen, CSGO jedes zweite Rank nennt einen Cheater. Die bashen wir jetzt.
Checkt. Guckt mal, findet ihr auch, dass das Pistolenmodel echt scheiße aussieht? Oder? Guckt
euch mal das Pistolenmodel an. Alter, was ist denn das? Das sah in Battlefield 1942 besser aus.
Wieso levelst du die Pistole? Weil ich Akimbo unlocken will. Ich will unbedingt Akimbo Pistols.
Achtung, Achtung, Outplay. Oh, fuck. Ich hab vergessen, Melee One-Hitted nicht mehr. Ich
will Akimbo freispielen. Das ist mein einziges Ziel, was ich für diese Beta noch hab. Ich
hab jetzt ein paar gute Gameplays erspielt. Ich hab eigentlich alles ausprobiert, was
man so ausprobieren muss. Mein einziges Ziel für die Beta ist jetzt noch, ich will noch
mal Akimbo Pistols spielen. Akimbo im zweiten Weltkrieg, ja klar. Das gibt jetzt keine 25
Gameplays oder so. Mal gucken, wie die Pistole ist. Das wird sich ja schon abzeichnen mit
der Zeit, wenn wir ein paar Attachments anlocken. Achtung, den outplayen wir jetzt. Alter, ey,
die Pistole. Lohnt sich nicht, man trifft nichts. Egal. Egal. Ich will das ausprobieren.
Ich will Akimbo Pistole ausprobieren. Da kommt er. Ich will Akimbo Pistole ausprobieren.
Mal gucken, wie das ist. Das ist das einzige, was ich in der Beta noch probieren will. Ich
will mal was. Vielleicht kriegen wir auch ein geiles Pistolen-Gameplay hin. Wobei ich es
bezweifle so kacke, wie die Konsole ist. Konsole? Hab ich gerade gesagt Konsole? Kann das sein?
Ich mein Pistole, ne? Aber Konsole auch. PC Master Race. So ist es halt. Aber man trifft
ja gar nichts. Der Typ levelt auch Pistole. Rekt. Aua. Ich find die Maps ganz gut. Äh,
das find ich bescheuert. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass du quasi jetzt spotten drückst.
Also wenn du in Battlefield drückst, dann sagst du irgendwas, dass er jetzt irgendwie
Enemy-Sniper spottet oder was auch immer. Aber hier schreien die Gegner automatisch
rum, wenn sie dich sehen. Das heißt, du hörst von hinten auf einmal den Gegner schreien
und weißt, hinter dir steht einer. Was also für den Gegner ziemlich kacke ist. Ne? Weil
du dann außen zu ihn halt. Achtung, krasser Flank. Krasser Flank. Bam. Na komm, immerhin
neun neun mit Pistole ist das doch ganz gut. Camper Faggot. Lul. Ich weiß gar nicht.
Ich geh mal davon aus, er meint mich gar nicht. Ich muss mir gleich mal angucken, was es noch
für Pistolen gibt und so Sachen halt. Was es noch für Pistolen gibt und was es für
Aufsätze gibt und sowas. Muss ich erst mal kurz gucken, ob sich das überhaupt lohnt
jetzt diese Pistole freizuspielen oder ob ich lieber hier G18 nehme oder wie das nicht
G18 ist. Es gibt irgendwie so eine Autopistole. Hab ich gesehen. Hahahaha. Akena, das erinnert
mich an die Gears of War Übersetzung. Oder, oder. Nee, das war Halo 4. Wo sie in your
face, wo die dann im Deutschen gesagt haben, in dein Gesicht. Das ist einfach fail. Scary
Leggy, du wartet immer noch auf Telefonmast. Ja, ich hoffe, die haben wieder diese Sprecher,
die das so geil betont haben wie in Call of Duty 2. Ich kann das gar nicht nachmachen.
Die haben so übertrieben, übertrieben ja geschrien und das so. Weißt du, die haben
so geschrien. Ich hab das doch hier irgendwo drinne. Telefonmast. Oh nee, jetzt ist das
Game gecrasht. Man darf nicht raustreppen, Leute. Man darf nicht raustreppen. Das ist
verboten. Nope. Nope. PC Master Race lohnt. Nicht bei Call of Duty. Ich hab's gewagt,
das Game zu switchen. Oh mein Gott. Ich hab, ich hab es gewagt, eine Anwendung zu switchen
in meinem Multitasking-Betriebssystem im Jahr 2017. Na, der kann schon mal schiefgehen,
ne? Max, wann zeigst du mal, was du so auf deinem Server laufen hast? Ähm, hab ich,
hab ich das nicht schon mal gezeigt? Oh, jetzt hat das Game ja wieder mein Mikro um.
Das ist halt auch so fail. Das Game stellt immer mein Mikrofon auf 100% wenn ich's neu
starte. RIP headphone users. Ja, keine Absicht. Aber ich, ich kann's mir einfach nicht immer
merken, dass ich das Mikrofon umstellen muss, sobald ich das Game neu starte. Obwohl ich
mir so langsam aber sicher merken können müsste, so oft wie das Game crasht. So, gucken
wir uns jetzt mal an. Oh guck mal, die ist schon Level 3. Easy, easy. Moment, Rang 33
für die Autopistole, das pack ich doch nie im Leben. Was bin ich denn gerade für ein
8? Naja, mal gucken, mal gucken. Aber Akimopistols muss sein. So, was? Äh, kann man, hat die
gar keine Aufsätze oder was? Hat die nur Aufsätze? Hat die nur Aufsätze mit dieser
Park oder wie oder was? Achso. Ich dachte, wenigstens einen Aufsatz kann man drauf machen.
Hm, na gut. Ok, dann montieren wir das mal. Next Game. Eine Runde Starcraft, nein, keine
Runde Starcraft. Ja, Timbo. Ganz bestimmt. Das haben wir die letzten Jahre ja. Die letzten
Jahre haben wir das ja gesehen. Hallo, Pistole. Ist das jetzt schneller? Ja, es geht schneller.
Die Map ist für Pistole. Oh guck mal, die ersten Macs gehen schon über Wallhack. Ja,
definitiv. Ihr guckt euch mal die Stats an von dem einen und der Name auch schon. Das
ist garantiert geht das nicht. Ähm, Moment. Ah, der mit seinen 25, das erscheint mir
doch noch nicht so ganz legit. Also wenn das jetzt total verhackt ist, dann hab ich
keinen Bock. Dann lassen wir das heute. Bäm. Next. Oh, jetzt wird geschneibert. Achtung,
Leute. Schneiber. Bäm. Next. Oh, das können wir auch mal machen. Da können wir Runde
Starcraft machen. Da hat's auch noch mal Bock drauf. Aber das Visier ist kacke von dem Typ.
So, mal triff ich nix. Wat? Ich war nicht drauf. It's time to aimbot. Perfekt. Oh, Mann, ey.
Ich warte trotzdem, bis das Game vorbei ist. Das. Das ist so fail. Ich meine, das ist
gut. Hallo? In der, in der. Zwei Tage nach Beta. Das Spiel ist dead auf dem PC noch bevor
es erscheint. Das ist auch toll, oder? Ich hab mich net getroffen. Wat? Pff. Pff. Pff.
Pff. Übrigens, ähm. Wer das letzte Mal dabei war, als ich das neue Ubuntu ausprobiert
hab im Stream. Was haltet ihr da? Pff. Legit. Legit. Ähm. Als ich das Ubuntu letztens im
Stream ausprobiert hab, wer dabei war, hat's ja mitgekriegt, dass das nicht so gut funktioniert
hat, was ich mir da überlegt hab. Ich könnte noch mal ein aktuelles, äh, Archlinux zeigen,
wie man das einrichtet für n' Desktop, für n' Desktopbetrieb in AVM. Haben das letzte
Mal ja auch ein paar Leute gefragt, als ich das, als ich die Ubuntu Installation da gezeigt
hab. Also wenn ihr das für ne gute Idee halt, kann ich das noch mal machen. Kam ja generell
ziemlich gut an. Hätt ich grad gedacht. Da haben wir irgendwie, irgendwie 150 Leute
zugeguckt, als ich, äh, den Ubuntu Installation durchgeklickt hab. Beziehungsweise danach
festgestellt hab, dass ich nicht copy-paste kann. Ups. Moment, das hab ich falsch ausgerüstet.
Super. Hab ich nicht mal meine Pistole. Hab ich. Ist der Typ eigentlich immer noch drinne
jetzt? Wie hieß denn der? Nee, der ist nicht mal drinne. Easy heißt er schon. Na wenn er
schon Easy heißt, dann will ich net wissen, ob er dat vielleicht doch anhat. Weil GG
ist. Oh. Oh, hier ist ein Sniper. Ich brauch die Sniper. Wo ist die Sniper? Eben war die
Sniper hier. Da, da, Sniper. Hier war doch eben ne Sniper. Wo ist die? Ah. Nee, das
ist gar keine Sniper. Ich will ne Sniper. Wir, wir snipe, wir snipen da noch ne Runde.
Aber wenn das so weitergeht, kann ich die Pistole, hab ich die Pistole sogar relativ
schnell gelöffelt. Links war was, der kommt jetzt hinterher. Der denkt, ich hab ihn net
gesehen. Oder nicht. Haha. Super, top. Ein Wack für das Spiel bekommen.
Bevor es erscheint. Das musste er auch mal schaffen, ne? Das musste er auch mal schaffen.
Ich find's halt krass, wenn man sich das überlegt. Ähm, sie haben im Vorfeld ja
wieder erzählt, so Dinger wie, wir möchten das Herz der PC-Spieler gewinnen und bla,
bla, bla. Da sieht man einfach mal, auch wenn's einem irgendwie schon klar gewesen ist,
ouch, dass, auch wenn's einem schon irgendwie klar gewesen ist, dass das einfach absolut
inhaltsleeres, sinnloses Marketing-Geschwärze ist. Wo man, man, wo man nichts drauf geben
darf, wirklich gar nichts. Hoffentlich ist die Pistole dann so weit, dass ich übernächstes
Game, übernächstes Game Akimbo ausprobieren kann. Hallo Naked, Naked Joker. Der Battlefield
2 Server ist noch da, ja, ja. Aber ich glaub, der ist grad leer. Aber ab und zu sind da
Leute drauf. Wat? Was war das jetzt grade, wie hat der mich so schnell gekillt? Ah,
mehle. Äh, schauen wir uns mal den Dedicated-Servers-Indicator an. Da haben wir grad gesehen, dass Agiga
schon mal keinen hat. Und wir haben ja auch gelernt, Dedicated-Servers ist in dem Fall
umgedreht, damit ist nicht etwa ein Server gemeint, sondern jeder hat seinen eigenen.
Sledgehammer kann's halt. Jeder hat seinen eigenen Dedicated-Server und man erkennt
das, ob man einen hat, hier neben an dieser Anzeige. Das ist nämlich kein Ping. Haben
wir gestern rausbekommen. Jetzt geht's, läuft's aber hier. Jetzt läuft's aber hier mit der
Pistole. Haben wir ne Sniper? Ich will ne Sniper haben. Ich will noch ein paar krasse Scopes
machen. Da. Nee. Ja, Timbo, jeder hat seinen eigenen Server. Und wenn du nett bist, kannst
du noch Leute auf deinen Server drauf lassen. Und die sind so gut bei Sledgehammer Games,
wenn du nicht mehr willst, dass die Leute auf deinen Server gehen und einfach ausschaltest,
dann werden die automatisch auf den anderen Server verschoben. Das ist aber geil, oder?
Das ist aber richtig 2017. Oh, hab ich mit Pistol-Only überhaupt ne positive KD? Der
Pistol-King ist am Start. Genau so sieht's aus, Nex. Okay, der Pistol-King. Der Pistol-Boss.
Der Pistol-Boss ist am Start. Pistol-Boss wurde von der Seite gesniped. Es gab doch
letztens auch schon ein Game, was in der Beta so total verhackt gewesen ist. Ich hab auch
vergessen, was das war. Was war denn das? War das vielleicht sogar das letzte Cod? Kann
das sein? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Es war letztens schon in dem Game, was während
der Beta schon komplett im Arsch gewesen ist. Nee, äh, war das die Battlefield Beta? War
das die Battlefield 1 Beta? Kann das sein? Wo auch schon krasse Wallhack-Gambot-Typen
am Start waren? Ich glaub, das war die Battlefield 1 Beta. Ja, Patrick, ich mach den Pistol-Only-Cheat.
Genau, Battlefield 1 war das. Das war Battlefield 1. Kann ich mich doch dran erinnern. Wie ist
das eigentlich? Mal eine Frage an die Leute, die Battlefield 1 spielen. Wie ist das da
so mit Hacker? Ich hab's ja nicht gekauft. Äh, For Ever Next meinste Age of Empires?
Heißt das ernsthaft Age of Empires 1 das nächste? Fangen wir jetzt auch da mit dieser
bescheuerten Nummerierung an? Ok. Ja, also in den Battlefield-Teilen vorher, es hielte
sich auch in Grenzen, ja. Nee, die COD 5 Beta hab ich nicht gespielt. Achso, Remaster
gibt's, ok, nee, keine Ahnung, hab ich mir nicht angeguckt. Äh, Dedicated Server Indicator,
die zwei haben keinen. Oh doch, jetzt haben sie auch einen. Wie haben sie das gemacht?
Ja, das hab ich auch schon mitgekriegt, Fatal. Vor allem, wenn man sich mal die Spielerzahlen
anguckt von Battlefield 1, ne. Also, ich hab's ja schon ein paarmal erzählt mittlerweile.
Battlefield 3, als das quasi der aktuelle Teil war, das haben so viele Leute gespielt.
Ich hab's ja damals auf der Xbox, ich hatte das auf allen Plattformen. Ausch. Ich hatte
das auf allen Plattformen. Am Schuss hatte ich auf dem PC, ich hatte es auf der PS3,
auf der Xbox 360. Hauptsächlich hab ich auf der Xbox 360 gespielt. Und man hatte da mit
der Zeit schon relativ viele Leute in der Freundesliste. Und wenn man geguckt hat, hat
man festgestellt, Battlefield 3 das komplette Jahr über, das wurde eigentlich konstant
gespielt. So. Oh fuck, WTF. Das wurde eigentlich konstant gespielt. So, und dann kam... Also,
ne, du hast... Fuck, wo kommt der her? Du hast geguckt, hast abends gesehen, hey, 100...
Was weiß ich... Äh, nicht 100, WTF. 10, noch was, Leute. Irgendwie. Freundesliste,
online, Battlefield 3. So, dann kam Battlefield 4 raus. WTF. So. Bam. Moment. War das kein
Mördendom oder sowas? So, dann kam Battlefield 4 raus und instant alle Leute aufgehört
zu spielen. Fuck. Instant alle Leute aufgehört zu spielen, alle in Battlefield 4 gewesen.
Zwei Wochen später, Battlefield 4, Freundesliste offline. So für'n Arsch, ey. So. Und, ähm,
daran hat man gesehen, dass das durchaus möglich ist, dass ein Battlefield-Game auch mal ohne
Probleme, denn ja, oder so, komplett, oder zwei Jahre, das hätte auch funktionieren
in Battlefield 3, die Leute halten kann. Da waren immer viele Leute an. So, und guckst
dir jetzt mal die Spielerzahlen von Battlefield 1 an. Das ist lächerlich. Battlefield 1 hat
ungefähr doppelt so viel... Was geht mit dem da ab? Ungefähr doppel... Was? Ungefähr
doppelt so viele Spielerzahlen wie Battlefield 4. Muss man sich mal vorstellen. Oh, ne Sniper.
Ich muss snipen. Komm her. Next please. Ach, ich dachte, der lebt noch. Ja, jetzt pass
auf hier, Max-Sniper-Action. Hardscope, Noob. Hardscope. Komm her. Was? Ey, neu... Ich
war doch drauf. Woher weißt du, dass die Spielerzahlen, wenn ein User, du kannst einfach mal BF-Stats,
kannst du, geh mal BF-Stats ein in Google, da findest du Stats-Seiten für, äh, Bad
in die 2, Battlefield 1, 3, 4, Hardline übrigens auch, wobei Hardline spielt halt keiner. Shotgun
in die Fresse. Auf dem PC waren es in Battlefield 1 um die 40k, das letzte Mal 40, 45k und
in Battlefield 4 25, 30k. So. Oder na, 20, 20 bis 25k nur in dem Dreh. Das ist halt
geil, ne? Das vorletzte oder vorverletzte, äh, Battlefield spielen quasi fast so viele
wie das neueste. Lol. W-W-Warum bin ich eigentlich instant tot immer? Kann mir das mal einer
erklären? Ach, weil er mich nahe gekämpft hat. Melet hat er mich. Melet. So, easy kills
please, kommt um die Ecke. Easy kills. Ach, keine easy kills. Hoffentlich hab ich nach
der Runde Akimbo frei. Weiß nicht wie lange das dauert. Aber ich werd das heut noch rauf
und runterspielen, bis ich keinen Bock mehr hab. Das Game, weil ich kaufs mir nicht. What?
Fuck. Nuaah, Call of Duty tot, ey. Äh. Ich. Ja. Ja, Kenny. Kenny? Brich mal das Kenny aus.
Was? Wie hat der mich denn jetzt getroffen? Ich lag hinter der Kiste. Ähm. Irgendwie
sieht das hinter der Kiste liegen tiefer aus als es beim Gegner aussieht, oder? Wieso
nicht kaufen, äh, Bubbleman? Weil das Game schon voller Hacker ist, voller Cheater und
sonst was. Und es kann mir keiner erzählen, dass es beim Release besser wird. Also wer
ernsthaft davon ausgeht, so nach dem Motto, ja, das ist jetzt ne Beta, ähm, da ist ja
bestimmt kein Anti-Cheat drin und deswegen, das wird beim Release alles besser, für'n
Arsch wird das besser. Also wer glaubt das wirklich, dass es bei Release besser wird?
Das wird bei Release auch nicht besser. Ähm. Dazu kommt, dass es instabil ist ohne Ende.
Okay, das könnte, oh fuck. Das könnte sich vielleicht ändern, beim Release. Das, okay,
ja, sag ich nix dagegen. Das lass ich mir gefallen. Ich lese gleich Chat, ich muss mich
gerade mal kurz konzentrieren. Alter Call of Duty Tode, immer von der Seite. Hoffentlich
ist meine Pistole danach fertig gelandet. Da gibt's Akemo Action. Ich hab da mal einen
Treiber geupdatet. Ich hab den neuesten, ich hab den neuesten, ein Videotreiber. Das
Raustappen haben alle. Das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst, oder? Jetzt wollte ich grad den
Typ jebaiten und jetzt ist das Game vorbei. Oh, Tommy, hast du da mal nen Link zu? Hast
du da mal nen Link zu? Er hat grad geschrieben, Activision hat irgendwie nen Post gemacht,
was sie noch verbessern wollen an der PC-Version. Hast du da mal nen Link zu? Das würd ich mir
gerne angucken. Ja, Maurice, die Hardcore-Fans. Ja, also man kann von allem Hardcore-Fans
sein und komplett die große Brille aufhaben. Felix, hab ich nicht? Okay. Können wir mal
im Stream machen? NakedJoker, der Friseur spielt quasi 24-7 Black Desert Online. Also gefühlt
24-7. So. Was macht denn die Pistole? Zeig her. Welches Level ist die jetzt? Fünf. Okay,
was brauch ich für Akimbo? Acht. Boah, das dauert ja ewig. Was für ein Level hab
ich? 28. Boah, das dauert ja ewig, bis ich da Akimbo hab. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir
das geben soll. Warte mal, ich mach mir das mal auf kurz. Ich hoffe, das Game kackt jetzt
nicht ab beim Raustappen. Man weiß ja nie. Das gucken wir uns gleich mal zusammen an.
Was Activision denn verbessern möchte. Hey, das Game ist nicht gekrasht beim Raustappen.
Ja, doch, der Link funktioniert. Du musst die Leerzeichen löschen. Mit der spanischen
TV-Show, ja. Von dem Typ gibt es total viele Videos. In echt, ne? Also, in dem echten
Interview hat der Typ irgendwas erzählt, dass er seine, ähm, was hat der erzählt,
dass er irgendwie seine Kochpfanne ins Meer gestellt hat und die wird dann weggespült
und so. Total langweilig. Aber halt, die ganzen Untertitel-Videos sind echt lustig.
Vor allem halt, wie er lacht. Und dass er halt keine Zähne hat. Ey! Pistole, bisschen
mehr Munition könnte das Ding auch haben. Ah, Hexo-Ingen, yeah! Wie heißt das Video
nochmal? Guck doch einfach mal. Guck einfach mal irgendwie Spanisch-Talkshow-Typ, der lacht
halt. Also mein Pistol-Level läuft sehr erfolgreich. Es macht aber auch einfach Spaß mit Hackern
zu spielen. Es gibt kaum was besseres als mit Hackern zu spielen. Ja, ist ja gut, ey.
Kannst du die jetzt mal töten? Oh, wenn das da Pfeiffer gehört hätte. Eieiei. Instant
Ban. Wir gucken uns das gleich mal an. Wir gucken uns gleich mal den Post an, was wir
noch alles verbessern wollen. 1-5-Wie! Das läuft ja gut mit Pistolen. NA-Aim. Ja, selbst
wenn du richtig auf die Gegner drauf bist, du schießt nicht genau dahin, wo du denkst,
dass du dahin schießt. Und man hat nur 8 Schuss. Was willst du denn da machen? Ins Knie! Guck
mal, was willst du mit der Pistole machen? Wir machen jetzt, wir spielen jetzt ordentlich
mit Pistolen. Das habe ich so gemacht. Oh, please, Koloff. Du, lass mich das mal auf
8 spielen. Ich will noch nur Level 8 auf der Pistole haben. Bombe. Ich will noch nur
Level 8 auf der Pistole. Das kann doch nicht so viel verlangt sein. Ich gehe da nicht
raus. Ha! Der, der Helzrad konnte aber ein bisschen schneller sein. Sind wir Gegner?
Wie soll man denn mit der Pistole, mit dieser Kackpistole Leute killen? Bis wann geht die
Beta noch? Bis heute Nacht. Ich sehe, ja, Matter Sky, ich sehe es auch schon kommen.
Ich habe das Ding Level 8, kann das erste Game Akimbo spielen, Beta vorbei. Ich kann
mir das so richtig vorstellen. Was? Hallo? Ich will das da, ey. Das gibt es nicht. Das
funktioniert ja gut. Oh, Pistol only. Krass. Es gibt ja zum Glück eh keine KD-Stats. No
Pistol. Pistole Level 8, please. Ha! Von rechts kommen die. Oh. Ja, ich sehe es.
Ja, ist ja gut. Das wird frustrierend, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe, die Pistole
auf Level 8 zu machen. Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, wir spielen jetzt 3-4 Runden, killen
ein paar Leute mit der Pistole Level 8, Akimbo ausprobieren, aber das ist ja der richtige
grind. Das ist der richtige grind. Übrigens ist es glaube ich ein Game ohne Hacker. Ich
habe die falsche Pistole genommen, warum? Warum ist das die falsche Pistole? Das ist
die beste Pistole. Forever Next habe ich schon jemals StarCraft gemacht, also selbst gespielt.
Ne, die vollautomatische kommt auf Level 33. Das ist doch scheiße damit was zu treffen.
Ne, guck, genau, die Pistole, die der hat, ist auch nicht automatisch. Die automatische
Pistole kommt auf 33 oder so. Ha!
Yolo, Yolo. Yolo, jetzt gehts ab.
Oh, ich hab nur noch 2 Schuss. Gut, mir bleibt jetzt ja nichts anderes übrig. Ich muss jetzt
das Ding hier verwenden. Jetzt läufts, ne? Kaum spielt man immer mit der Pistole läufts.
Ja, das Spiel kann so schön sein, weil man Leute killen kann, weil man nicht mit Pistole
spielen muss. Jetzt werden sie aber gereckt, oder? Jetzt werden sie gereckt. Ja, klippen,
PogChamp, klippen, klippen, please. Das war jetzt irgendwie, naja, 15 Kills nicht, aber
10. Wie hättest du die Battlefronts 2 Beta zocken?
Scyther HD, hm, wann ist denn die? 4.10, ah, das heißt, 4.10, also übermorgen.
Ja, ich guck Discord. Ja, werd ich mal ausprobieren, aber ich glaube, dass mich das Game nicht
packen wird. Battlefront 1, also die erste Neuauflage hat mir nicht gefallen. War einfach
nicht meins. So, welches Level haben wir denn jetzt mit der Pistole? Alter, immer noch
Level 5? Wann die, oder, äh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Auf gogo, next game!
Mercy main by the way.
Oh, da ist wieder die beste Pistol Map aller Zeiten.
Gogo!
Ich schmeiße eine Betäubungsgranate! Oh, da hat der Sprecher aber Spaß gehabt.
Ich mach demnächst wieder mehr Videos.
Ich hab's kapiert.
Einfach mal in die Richtung gesprayed.
Der Level auch Pistole, der Typ.
Das gibt's doch net, ey.
Der hatte die bessere Pistole. Das ist ganz einfach, easy.
Das muss, das kann nicht daran liegen, dass ich nicht getroffen hab. Der hatte die bessere Pistole.
Moment, sind die Don'ts gesporn?
Hä?
What the fuck?
Check ich net.
Auch wenn ich die Pistole auf Level 8 hab, muss ich noch was Normales spielen.
Hey, guck mal wer da ist.
Guck mal wer da ist.
Next, next please.
Achso, jetzt gehen wir hier dran.
Kommt her, Köpfe rausstrecken.
Köpfe raus.
Was?
What the fuck?
Der ist hinter uns gesporn, ne?
Hm.
Das ist aber sehr fairer Spornpunkt.
Outstripen, outstripen.
Doch, doch, die Levels werden resetten. Alles andere kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Aber nachdem ich mir das Game nicht kaufen werde,
ähm, will ich jetzt noch mal Akimbo Pistole ausprobieren.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie sich mit der Beta in dieser Form gefallen getan haben.
Das Game ist nicht schlecht.
Also ich kann gegen, gegen das eigentliche Gameplay, wenn man halt eben Call of Duty Gameplay mag,
wenig ansteigen.
Aber der ganze Cheaterscheiß ist halt schon wieder auch gar nicht lächerlich.
Please don't hack.
Deswegen, dann sagt er sich, der sagt sich jetzt, ja, also,
ich kann das eigentliche Gameplay, wenn man halt eben Call of Duty Gameplay mag,
wenig sagen.
Please don't hack. Deswegen, dann sagt er sich, der sagt sich jetzt, ja, also,
Relative PV jetzt, jetzt, weil jetzt wurde es gesagt, dass ja, ich installiere jetzt X22.
Denkt er sich jetzt, ganz bestimmt.
Ganz bestimmt.
Weil, weil irgendein Hacker, Cheater, was auch immer,
schon aufgehört hat zu hacken, cheaten, weil einer gesagt hat, please don't cheat.
Ich bin immer instant tot.
Was ist denn da los?
Was sagt denn der Dedicated Server Indicator?
Ha, da sagt es.
Gibt es nicht.
Und nochmal hier was zu diesen Balken.
Man macht sowas nur, oh Level 6, geht vorwärts, geht vorwärts, geht vorwärts.
Man macht sowas einfach nur, wenn man was zu verstecken hat.
Nur, wenn man was zu verstecken hat.
Weil, warum kann man nicht einfach einen Ping anzeigen?
Man muss ihn ja eh wissen.
Das kann, das einzige, wie ich mir das erklären kann, ist,
man möchte Scheißverbindungen verschleiern.
Das ist das einzige, was ich mir erklären kann, warum man keine Pinganzeige macht.
32.1, seems legit.
Mann, ist der guter Typ.
Er ist so gut.
Er ist so guter Typ.
Es hat ja auch keinen Sinn, sich darüber aufzuregen.
Ich finde, es gibt zwei Seiten der Medaille.
Klar, man kann sich jetzt über diesen, über den Typ aufregen,
der sich hier Jeets runtergeladen hat und sowas.
Zu Recht kann man sich über den aufregen.
Aber, da gehören zwei dazu.
Da gehören natürlich einmal Leute, oder sag mal drei gehören dazu.
Es gehören einmal Leute dabei, die halt andere Leute abfacken wollen
oder aus irgendwelchen Gründen, was auch immer,
gibt es da verschiedene, ja, seems legit,
gibt es da verschiedene Gründe, warum sich einer sowas runterlädt,
dass sie sowas haben wollen.
Dann gibt es Leute, die sowas für das Game entwickeln
und dann gehören auch die Entwickler dazu,
wenn sie es den Leuten so einfach machen wie bei diesem Code.
Guckt euch mal Overwatch an.
In Overwatch gibt es ab und zu mal, es ist nicht komplett cheaterfrei,
ab und zu mal gibt es Cheater, aber es ist wirklich wenig.
Wenn man das hier vergleicht mal mit Overwatch Ranked, ist es der Witz.
Das ist der absolute Witz.
Overwatch Ranked hatte ich vielleicht in der EU leder bisher 10 Cheater.
Seit Anfang an.
Ich bin quasi seit der ersten Beta-Phase dabei in dem Game
und bis jetzt, was weiß ich, ich hab da wahrscheinlich
irgendwie 1000 Stunden oder so mittlerweile drin,
hatte ich vielleicht 10 Cheater oder sowas in dem Dreh.
Ja, in Korea ist es auch in Overwatch schlimmer,
aber hier in der EU leder nix.
Blizzard macht es den Leuten halt auch nicht so einfach.
Blizzard hat ordentlichen Server, worauf das Game läuft,
wo halt keiner Zugriff drauf hat, außer Blizzard selbst
und schon gar nicht irgendwelche Möchtegern, Hexer.
Und wenn du gebannt wirst wegen Cheat, ist halt Account weg,
kannst du neu kaufen.
Ja, genau, Xerathus, so ist es.
Das ist auch richtig so.
Wenn du gecheated hast, Account weg.
Das muss ja natürlich unterscheiden.
Es geht hier jetzt um competitive Multiplayer-Sachen,
wo gecheated wird.
Wenn jetzt irgendjemand, keine Ahnung, GTA V spielt
und dort im Singleplayer sich irgendwelche Waffen
entcheatet oder sowas.
Hey, das kann er machen, das juckt mich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr dazu steht, aber ich unterscheide
die Sachen immer so prinzipiell in zwei Sachen.
Erstmal ist es Singleplayer oder Multiplayer.
Singleplayer ist es mir scheißegal, ob einer cheatet.
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Null.
Multiplayer schon.
Singleplayer kann jeder cheaten, wie er will.
Ist mir scheißegal.
Ich habe auch schon in irgendwelchen Singleplayer-Games
irgendwelche Config-Files editiert oder irgendwelche
Skill-Punkte oder was auch immer.
Einfach, weil ich keinen Bock habe, nochmal neu anzufangen
oder sowas.
Weil, wenn man in Singleplayer-Games cheatet,
dann versaut man sich im schlimmsten Fall selbst
den Spaß daran.
Mehr kann eigentlich nicht passieren.
Und dann ist man selbst dran schuld, letztendlich.
Also es bleibt bei einem selbst.
Wenn man allerdings jetzt in Multiplayer-Spielen...
WTF?
Kommt der her.
Wenn man jetzt allerdings in Multiplayer-Spielen cheatet,
und das gibt es natürlich auch noch in unterschiedlichen
Ausprägungen.
Es gibt sowas, sagen wir mal...
Es gibt sowas, wie sagen wir mal...
Diablo 2 Map Hack.
Ist auch cheat, ist auch scheiße.
Ja.
Aber ich finde, es ist noch ein Unterschied
zu, sagen wir mal, einem Diablo 2 Map Hack.
Ups.
Als zu einem Aimbot und Wall Hack.
In einem Shooter.
Klar, ist auch irgendwo verwerflich.
Gegner.
Meine Sensitivity ist auch...
nicht so ganz, wie ich es gewohnt bin.
Fällt mir gerade auf.
Der wird gebashed.
Bashed Reno.
Was?
Oh, Sniper.
Wo ist der Typ?
Ich will den snipen.
Ist das überhaupt eine Ball-Action?
Ja.
Jetzt wird gesniped.
Sniper-Action.
Krass, Sniper-Action.
Go, go, go.
Sniper, Sniper.
Ich sehe nichts.
Sniper.
Wo sind denn die Gegner?
Ich will mal snipen.
Ha.
Hier.
No Scope.
High Skill.
Was?
Das erste war doch schon drauf.
Das war auch...
Ich hätte...
Also wenn meine Sensitivity halbwegs stimmt mit dem, was ich gewohnt bin, war das drauf.
Aber es kann doch einfach sein, dass meine Sensitivity nicht so ganz dem entspricht, wie ich mir das einbilde.
Aber ich ersetzte schon mal einen Clip, wo ich auf war dreimal durch den Gegner gesniped habe.
Wo sind die Gegner?
Wo ist denn hier was?
Ich will jetzt hier krasse Sniper-Action machen, da ist nichts da.
Und so, jetzt kommen sie bestimmt von da.
Oder nicht?
Von wo kommt jetzt was?
Ich bin verwirrt.
Ich will jetzt einmal über die Map geraten, das war nichts.
Aber hier sind meine Leute, das heißt, die müssen jetzt eigentlich von hier kommen.
Hallo?
Gegner?
Gegner please, wo seid ihr denn?
Keiner da.
Einfach mal reingerannt.
Oh, Pistol wieder.
Ich will doch nur Level 8 mit der Pistole haben.
Plus RNG.
Ich mache mir da jetzt gar keine Mühe, Games zu suchen ohne Cheater.
Ich bleib einfach drin und Level meine Pistole.
Janus Müller, ich finde auch, also mein Aim und das, was man letztens dort in der Killcam gesehen hat, ist zum Verwechseln ähnlich.
Link ansehen.
Ja, Moment.
So, gucken wir uns das jetzt mal zusammen an.
Ich musste mal kurz durchlesen.
Okay.
Entwickler reagiert auf durchwachsendes Feedback.
Gucken wir uns nach der Runde an.
Ich versuche jetzt noch einmal Pistole frei zu spielen.
Es sei denn das Game crashed wieder.
Dann nicht.
Eine Runde machen wir noch.
Moment.
Also wir spielen doch jetzt gerade quasi als Wehrmachtstyp gerade, oder?
Also auch wenn man da aufpassen muss, was wir in der heutigen Zeit sagen.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir erstens so viele Frauen an der Front hatten und zweitens auch noch schwarze Frauen an der Front für die Wehrmacht.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so ganz akkurat.
Aber das ist ja heutzutage schwierig, wenn man sowas sagt, dann ist man gleich entweder Sexist, Rassist oder in Kombination quasi.
Ja, mir fällt da kein gescheites Wort in Kombination ein.
Sexist.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, so ganz akkurat ist das nicht.
Der wird geregt, der Typ da steht hinter der Mauer.
Nee, steht da nicht.
Warum nicht?
Baschen, alter Baschen.
Äh, ich schwung gerade Ronny.
Also bis heute hatten wir glaube ich fünf.
Cheater, verschiedene.
Von sehr offensichtlich im Aimbot, bis zu Ballhack, bis zu...
Was zum Teufel geht denn hier ab?
Da kriegst du ihn.
Schön um die Ecke gekillt, auch gut, nice.
Suche Gegner, keine da.
Jedes Game ein Cheater, ja kommt hin.
Der Akimbo Pistol ist absolut historisch akkurat.
Ich kann meinen Opa leider nicht mal fragen.
Die 720 Scopes, ich habe schon Probleme gerade 360 hinzukriegen mit meinem Mouthpad.
Also das geht gerade so, gerade so kriegt man das hier hin.
Hast du nicht mit deinem Opa mal ein Video gemacht?
Doch, habe ich schon ein paar Jahre her.
Warum bin ich Zweiter?
Pistol only gibt es noch nicht.
Da links war noch einer, genau gesehen.
Da war doch noch einer drinne hier.
Bombe, bleiben wir mal hier versteckt drinne.
Hier kann eigentlich nicht viel passieren drinne.
Tja, nachladen, es ist halt ein bisschen fail, dass er rum schreit, no ammo, no ammo.
Da weißt du gleich, du kannst jetzt um die Ecke rausrennen.
Um die Ecke rausrennen ohne Killen.
Get turned on.
Nee, Dropshoten ist out, Dropshoten macht man nicht, wenn man Jumpshotet jetzt.
Jumpshoten besser.
Ich habe Input lag, bewegt sich nicht.
Perfekt.
Dropshots ist out.
Oh, ich bin mit Pistole Level 8, ich kriege Anfälle langsam.
Ich kriege wirklich Zustände.
Und ich vermute mal, die Level-Raten und XP-Raten sind schon erhöht.
Was, was?
Commander Krieger Aim.
Der Level auch Pistole.
Massive Kills.
Huge Kills.
Ich finde die Caster bei Overwatch immer so geil.
Eines der Lieblingswörter, was sie haben, ist irgendwie huge.
Und wenn es nicht mehr huge genug ist, dann ist es massive.
Und warum, warum darf ich hier übrigens jetzt nicht raus und schon das neue Game suchen?
PMA Boys.
Ja, Nexo, das war jetzt nicht sonderlich PMA, da hast du recht.
Infinite Knowledge.
Ich sehe, da guckt einer Taimo.
Taimo, bester Overwatch-Streamer.
Ich gucke jeden Stream von ihm.
Fast jeden Stream.
Wenn er irgendwann nachts um 5 streamt oder...
Nein, ich hatte kein Spaß, letztes Match.
Increased Sprint.
Oh, wir sind 29.
Das heißt, wir sind gerade das richtige Level für Autopistole, wenn man die aktuelle Pistole auf Akimbo hat.
Oh.
Verlockend.
Ja, Magazin, das brauche ich.
Big Troll juckt mich nicht.
Headshot Damage.
Das reicht immer noch, wir machen Headshot Damage.
Das ist eine ganz gute Kombination jetzt.
Das erste.
Welches Level hatten die Waffe jetzt eigentlich gehabt?
Sechs.
Okay, noch eineinhalb Level Pistole.
Das überleben wir, das überleben wir.
Suche hackerfreie Lobby.
Kannste...
Oh, vergesse es.
Es war nicht die F4-Taste.
Wenn ich eine Taste hemmere, ist es immer, immer Leertaste.
Jetzt bin ich vom Lucio-Spielen so gewöhnt.
Lucio.
Warcraft hier.
Ich habe mehr Munition.
Nice.
Das ist ein Sniper, das heben wir jetzt auf von...
Turn on.
Heckt.
Jetzt habe ich endlich mal ordentlich Munition mit der Pistole.
Massive Kids.
Massive.
Hit please Level 8.
Unglaublich, dass mir fast 200 Leute zugucken, wie ich Pistole level.
Oh.
Warum ist das so schnell umgefallen?
Heckt.
Ja, ja das Tier, das sehe ich auch so.
Also mir tun wirklich die Leute leid, die das Game vorbestellt haben.
Massive Geld zum Fenster rausgeschmissen.
Das X-Tier, stimmt.
Es ist nicht das Tier, es ist das X-Tier.
Ja, es tut mir leid, das habe ich jetzt verkackt.
Das ist schon wichtig, das X da drinnen.
Oder es war nicht das X, das X-Tier.
Tja, wäre ich mal nicht an der Wand hängen geblieben.
Aber mir tun die Leute auch, bin ich nicht gerade hier gestorben und jetzt wieder gespawrt?
Mir tun auch die Leute auch, die das vorbestellt haben.
Wo ist hier was?
Hier kommt was?
Da ist er.
Oh nee, jetzt wissen sie, dass wir hinter ihnen sind.
Wo sind sie?
Bei der Gelegenheit, eigentlich müsste ich mir die Maps mal angucken, wie die so gemacht
sind.
Ich habe mir null angeguckt, so drum herum bisher.
Was auch schön wäre, wenn man in Game schauen könnte, wie weit die Waffen schon gelevelt
sind und sowas.
Da wüsste man, man hat es bald geschafft.
Wie wäre es, wenn das stimmt?
Früher habe ich jeden Call of Duty, oh Level 7, es geht vorwärts Jungs, es geht vorwärts.
Mittlerweile ist es so, dass jeder, der sich cool fühlt in Wilhelms Cream einbaut in seine
Games.
Früher war das so Running Gag, heute warten die Leute schon drauf.
Haha, rekt.
18-8 mit Pistole, nice.
Das war jetzt fast ein Halo Kill, oder?
Das war so ein typischer Halo Kill.
Halo Kills geht auch immer so, bäm bäm bäm bäm bäm bäm.
Stimmt es, oder habe ich recht?
Das war die Bombe, das geht da.
Von AVM.
Boah, das war schlecht.
AVM Fritzbombe.
Wie gestern einer geschrieben hat, passende UL dazu, fritz.bombe.
Was?
Shotgun!
Wie so eine Spritzbombe, weil es ja die Deutschen sind.
Und sie ja jedes Weltkriegsklischee irgendwie bedienen müssen.
Ich habe noch ein Level mit dieser Kackpistole, dann gibt es Akimbo Action.
Massive Akimbo Action.
Patrick, der ist bestimmt im fertigen Game dann auch dabei.
Hatte die heute eigentlich frei?
Oder musste die heute arbeiten?
Sprint Speed, noch besser für Akimbo Pistole.
Falloff Range ist auch sehr, sehr nice.
Aber braucht man nicht, Akimbo braucht man.
Ich würde sagen, Akimbo spielt man dann am besten mit Steady Aim.
Wahrscheinlich, aber eins, nee eins müsste man Akimbo Extended Max spielen.
Wie, es geht nur Akimbo.
Ich habe doch zwei, ich habe doch zwei Stats.
Und echt mit Akimbo kann man nichts mehr drauf machen.
Das ist ja noch nicht so geil, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Oh, nice Hex, fängt schon gut an die Runde.
Moment, hinter mir?
Wer hackt denn, der 91er?
Der 91er hackt, naja, war ein Zweier bei uns.
Jetzt geht es aber ab mit der Pistole.
Na wer hat jetzt hier die Hex, wer hat die Hex?
Ich bin entlarvt.
Ich muss mich gleich mal klippen.
Ich finde es cool, neun null mit der Pistole.
War da irgendwie was?
Bald Paratrooper, Troopers.
Oh nee.
Ein Kill noch, ein Kill noch.
Eineinhalb.
Jetzt noch den Gegner ankratzen.
Moment, ja, wir haben den übelsten Cheatertyp wieder dabei.
Oh man, ja kill mich.
Scheiße, das sagt so.
Warum haben wir einen Cheater immer?
Oh man, das Game ist doch überhaupt nicht spielbar so.
Das ist eine Scheiße.
Ja, super.
Das Game ist einfach schon tot bevor es rauskommt.
Good job.
Grandioses Aim.
Erstes Aim.
Lull.
Nee, ich kann nicht leaven.
Wenn ich leave, kriege ich keine Pistolen XP.
Ich will Pistolen XP.
Wow, ist das gut.
Das war gut.
Was, ein geiler Typ.
Okay, letztes Game, dann habe ich Akimbo am Start.
In Black Ops 1 war das auch ziemlich gut.
Es gab faktisch zu Zeiten, wo das Game angesagt war,
also sprich, dass eine Yabbis das nächste Call of Duty rausgekommen ist,
die Yabbis in Black Ops 1 fast keine Hex war.
Ich will euch noch an die Black Ops 1 Zeit erinnern,
wo es da Leute gab, die das auf der Wii gespielt haben
und erzählt haben, dass es die beste Version ist.
Oh, wir haben den Cheater im Gegnerteam.
Das war er übrigens.
Nächstes, jetzt das gleiche Game,
müssen wir jetzt wieder gegen den Typen spielen.
Ja, Cheats und dann noch Auto-Shotgun mit Brandmunition.
Wow.
Typischer Call of Duty Fight.
Spasten-Schneiper gegen einen komischen Panic-Knifer.
Auto-Shotgun mit Brandmunition, das kann nur kurz sein.
Vor allem auch im zweiten Weltkrieg, überhaupt kein Ding.
Ich gab es im zweiten Weltkrieg überhaupt in der Auto-Shotgun.
Und Tschüss.
Ich habe mich noch einmal geschneipt.
Das war einfach die... Moment.
Fake Parry, ist da alles in Ordnung bei dem Typ?
Das muss ich mir gleich nochmal angucken.
Ich habe da gerade so einen Eindruck gehabt.
Da stimmt was, nein.
Von wo trifft mich da was?
Achtung, Achtung.
Ich dachte, wir können erst mal richtig krass rauskommen, der Typ.
Also das gerade Cheater gegen Cheater, kann das... Nee.
Unser ist... Nee, ich glaube wir haben zwei Cheater im Gegnerteam.
Jawoll.
Also ich glaube, wenn ich die...
Wenn ich Pistolen-Akimbo ausprobiert habe, höre ich auf mit Kot.
Wenn ihr wollt, könnten wir noch eine Runde Battlefield 3 auf meinem Server spielen.
Den der Patrick eingerichtet hat.
Hättet ihr da Lust drauf?
Dann machen wir das doch.
Wer noch kein Battlefield 3 installiert hat, kann das in der Zwischenzeit ja schon mal machen.
Wenn er mitspielen will.
Der Server hat keine...
DLCs aktiviert.
Ja klar.
Ja du hast bestimmt noch eine halbe Stunde 45 Minuten Zeit zum installieren denke ich mal.
Das fühlt sich teilweise so schwammig an irgendwie.
Max, bist du in der Beta schon einem Cheater begegnet? Nee.
Ich glaube das ist nicht möglich.
Ich glaube das ist nicht möglich. Ravensoft und Sledgehammer haben einfach so...
So eine Expertise was Anti-Cheat angeht.
Da kann man von ausgehen, das ist einfach nicht möglich zu cheaten.
Man darf das auch nicht immer direkt alles auf Cheats schieben Leute.
Es gibt einfach Spieler die sind gut.
Der hier zum Beispiel, der ist übertrieben gut dieser LWBP.
Man darf nicht immer sagen hier der cheatet oder sonst was.
Man muss sich da an die eigene Nase fassen und sagen ja Leute es gibt einfach Spieler die sind besser als ich.
Gut das war jetzt wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht gecheatet.
Nee das war jetzt okay.
Das war jetzt legit.
Ja die haben eine gute Maus, ein gutes Mauspad und wie es gerade einer auch im Chat geschrieben hat
guten Spiele, einen guten Gaming-Chair.
Dann sind die halt einfach so gut.
Ein gutes Headset, gute Soundkarte.
Dann kann man schon mal 5 Leute nur mit Headshots ownen.
überhaupt kein Ding. Easy.
Ich will doch nur meine Pistole auf Level 8 kriegen.
Und Gaming Classes, hast du recht Kenny, Gaming Classes.
Gunner Optik.
Was?
Oder wie es Taimo sagen würde.
Wir haben so viel Wissen erlangt durch diesen Death jetzt.
Nur vom Verlieren besser.
Nur Verlieren macht uns stark.
Gewinnen kann jeder.
Nur Verlieren bringt einen weiter.
Ich hätte jetzt gerne Level 8 auf der Pistole, dass ich mit dem Game aufhören kann.
Das siehst du falsch Maestro.
Das siehst du falsch.
Sag mal kann das sein, dass wir 3 Cheater im Gegnerteam haben?
Na wobei, 23-12, das geht schon.
Verlieren ist das neue Gewinn, so sieht es aus.
Nur wer verliert kann danach besser gewinnen.
So ist es einfach.
Wenn ich nicht so viel Taimo geguckt wüsste ich das gar nicht.
Man muss das einfach alles positiv sehen.
Das heißt ich sehe das jetzt auch gar nicht schlimm, dass wir laufen gegen Cheater spielen.
Im Prinzip sorgen diese Cheater eigentlich dafür, dass ich selbst noch besser spiele danach.
Ich wechsle mal die Lobby.
Was redet er auch noch?
Was geht mit dem?
Warum kann der reden?
So habe ich das Ding jetzt endlich Level 8.
Ja Tommy ich gucke mir gleich den Link an.
Ich habe ihn schon aufgemacht.
Nein, nein, nein, wir müssen noch 2 Kills machen oder so.
Das machen wir jetzt noch schnell.
Tommy ich gucke mir das gleich an.
Und dann schauen wir uns nach dieser Runde an, wenn ich mal Akimbo Pistols ausprobiert habe.
Schauen wir uns an, was Sledgehammer der Meinung ist, was man an der PC Version von
den neuen Call of Duty noch verbessern könnte.
Man muss sagen, das Game ist ja nahezu an der Perfektion dran schon.
Da kann man nicht mehr viel verbessern.
Hast du mal Stellung gespielt?
Nee, Stellung noch nicht.
Domination ist das, das gehe ich mal von aus.
Ich habe nur Team Deathmatch und ein bisschen War gespielt.
Der wurde auch gerade von Dedicated Server geowned, der Typ.
Der hätte mich eigentlich locker ownen müssen.
8171.
Hardpoint bockt am meisten.
Verlieren ist keine Schande.
Jawoll Level 8.
Darf ich jetzt quitten?
Wenn ich jetzt quitte, ist dann die Pistole immer noch Level 8.
Please, Pistole Level 8.
Dann nehmen wir jetzt gerne.
Hä?
Ich habe nur die Auswahl zwischen zwei Attachments.
Was ist denn?
Moment.
Was geht in den Ihrem Kopf vor?
Standardmäßig kann ich kein Attachment auf die Pistole machen.
Ich brauche eine Perk für zwei Attachments.
Wenn ich aber Akimbo auswähle, darf ich wiederum ein Attachmentslot nicht verwenden.
Suche Logik.
Suche Logik, wir snipen jetzt.
Easy Sniper.
Nehme mal die Hauptwaffe raus.
Okay.
Meinst du das bringt was?
Nussmöller, das probiere ich gleich mal aus.
Bringt das was, wenn man die Hauptwaffe rausnimmt?
Kriegt man dann einen Slot?
Probiere ich jetzt mal aus.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Ich probiere das jetzt aus.
Wie remove man überhaupt eine Waffe?
Geht das überhaupt?
Geht überhaupt nicht.
Man kann keine Waffe remove.
Funktioniert nicht.
Nope.
Okay.
Jetzt gibt es Akimbo Pistole.
Und dann gucken wir uns den Link von Tommy an, was Sledgehammer und Ravensoft sagen, was man noch verbessern kann an dem Game.
So.
Wie, muss ich jetzt mit link...
Oh, ich muss mit linker und rechter Maus schießen?
Alter.
Ich kann so nicht spielen, linke und rechte Maus, dass du gleichzeitig...
Bin ich Stavierspieler oder wie, oder was?
Das ist ja mal richtig hängen geblieben.
Das ist mega bescheuert, da kann ich meine Maus nicht bewegen dabei, wenn ich linke und rechte Maus, dass du gleichzeitig drücken musst.
Das ist ja räudig, ey.
Du Scheiße.
Das passt auch mit meinem Mausgriff überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Ich greife meine Maus ja so, dass ich quasi hauptsächlich auf der linken Seite halte und ordentlich schnell links...
Ey, nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Stundenlange grinded für nix.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Ja, man kann das Setting bestimmt anders binden, aber das ist ja dann noch schlechter.
Soll ich linke Maustaste und X oder was binden?
Dann muss ich linke Maustaste und X drücken für Akimbo.
Ha, rekt.
Rext.
Entsetzliche Akimbo-Stellzee ist am Start. Jetzt werde er geschneibt.
Rekt.
Oder auch nicht.
Das war schon immer so, ja, mit dem Controller ist es ja auch kein Ding, mit dem Controller links und rechts zu schießen.
Ich erinnere mich noch an hier Dual-Python-Dings in Playgrounds 1.
Das war auch richtig geil.
Hardscope. Hardscope only.
Pschu, pschu.
Jetzt werden sie Hardscoped.
Makro, alles auf links, ja.
Ich werde mir jetzt gerade noch ein Makro dafür installieren.
Da hat er ihn, da hat er ihn.
Da wird er geschneibt.
Da wird er geschneibt. Jetzt geht es ab.
Sniperino.
Ich müsste noch Luft anhalten nehmen.
Hardscope, richtig krasse Hardscope-Action.
Aber schön gesniped haben wir hier, schön gesniped.
Was ich soll das auch für Sixty-Kills machen? Guckt euch an, guckt euch an, passt auf, passt auf Leute jetzt.
Hier, Achtung.
So sieht es aus.
Get Shrecked.
Schallschwackbann.
Braucht man das?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Das Sack bestimmt, das ist bestimmt viel zu groß.
WPPD, ja. Geht doch wieder.
Gab es denn überhaupt jemals diesen Laptop?
Ja, Key Worm mit Spin-Halt-Luxio-Movement gehört, da hat man es nicht so mit durch Türe laufen.
So, wir spielen jetzt noch mal eine Runde Sniper und dann schauen wir uns mal an, was Sledgehammer so sagt, was noch verbessert werden muss.
Und wenn sie denken, wenn sie denken, wenn sie denken, sie haben mich outmoved, die Jäger, dann Akimbo Pistol.
Skill-Granate.
Das war nix.
Aber kein krasser Stau.
Geht es jetzt besser ohne Hacks? Nö, jedes Game verhackt. Man kann es spielen, ich spiele.
Achtung. Achtung.
Oh Mann. Fuck, ich hab den hier vergessen. Ich hab den vergessen vorher.
Hä?
Aim. Aim. Bestes Aim. NA-Aim.
Achtung. Der wird jetzt, der wird jetzt rauskommen.
Was? Alter, was soll ich?
Habt ihr gesehen, wie ich mich gedreht hab, gedreht hab bei dem Typ?
Ich komm mit dem Scope nicht klar, das andere war besser.
Ich treff mit dem Ding nix.
Ich treff mit diesem Scheiß Scope nix. Unglaublich.
Oh.
Ich wollte den zu 16 und ich hab noch nicht mal den zu 16 gemacht.
Der Scope ist wirklich grausam, ja.
Jetzt hab ich sie verwirrt, jetzt haben sie gedacht, ich bin hilfloser geiler Sniper.
Jetzt komm ich mit den Alchemopistols um die Ecke.
Achtung, Flank.
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, was die Jungs noch am Spiel verbessern wollen und dann reicht's.
Noch kein Blödsinn mehr hier.
Wir haben es durchgespielt. End vom Lead Level 30.
Mal alles ausprobiert, was so ging. Von Snipern bis Assault Rifles bis Alchemopistolen.
Wir haben alles durch und das Spiel ist tot, bevor es auf dem PC rauskommt.
Good Job. So, jetzt gucken wir mal was verbessert werden soll noch.
Ich blende das mal kurz ein.
So, das scheint ein GameStar Artikel zu sein.
Entwickler reagieren auf Feedback zur PC-Beta. Verbesserung in Arbeit.
Aha, viele Spieler sind unglücklich mit der aktuellen PC-Beta.
Oh mein Gott, wer hätte das vermuten können?
Entwickler, Sledgehammer, hört aber auf, dass wir...
Ja, das sagen sie immer. So haben wir im Vorfeld auch gesagt, sie wollen das Herz der PC-Spieler gewinnen.
Guckt euch einfach die letzten Streams an. So gewinnt man das Herz der PC-Spieler.
So macht man das. Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Unzufrieden sind viele Spieler. Das ist richtig. Was...
Schreibe ich auch was von Cheatern?
Hatte? Hatte? GameStar hatte?
Oh, die Steam... Steam... ähm... ähm... ähm... ähm... ähm... ähm...
Dings.
Das Team müssen wir uns noch mal angucken. Die Steam-Bewertung müssen wir uns anschauen. Das ist bestimmt lustig wieder.
Ähm...
Cheater bei Open Beta. Nichts ungewöhnliches. Ja, den Overwatch habe ich glaube ich nicht eingesehen.
Natürlich nicht, natürlich nicht.
Naja, das ist aber schön geredet. Okay, also was wollen sie denn noch verbessern?
Was wollen sie noch... wir gucken uns das Original an, auf Reddit.
Äh... der Conry, das ist der, der mit dem eckigen Kopf, der immer da die Interviews kippt.
Werden in Kürze behoben, aber sind schon behoben. Login-Probleme, Ladescreen und Verbindungsfehler.
Login-Problem hat schon nicht Eines. Crashes in Matches, ja, sollte man beheben. Kleine Renderingfehler.
Nein, aber das ist das kleinste Problem bei dem Game. Ach, Crashes, keine Ahnung. Unbegrenztes Laden und Timeouts.
Keine Ahnung, hatte ich jetzt eigentlich auch nicht. SMG-Schaden und Reichweite, ging eigentlich, finde ich, in Ordnung.
Das ist mir vollkommen egal. Wie wäre es mal mit einem Wort zu cheatern, Jungs? So.
Wie wäre es mit einem Wort zu cheatern?
Hat er noch mehr gepostet hier drinnen?
Nö. Ja, das ist ja nichts sagen.
Gucken wir mal, ob es hier was zum Thema Cheater gibt.
Das kommen wir, das stimmen wir jetzt mit ab. Das stimmen wir jetzt mit ab.
Afterplaying PC Beta.
Meine Experience war dank Cheater ziemlich scheiße. An sich macht das Game, aber ach so, ich muss mich anmelden. Nee, dann doch nicht.
So, und jetzt gucken wir uns als letztes nochmal die Steam-Bewertungen an.
Lull.
Die ja sehr gut sein müssen, wie es hier aussieht.
Du, was? Du hast nicht den ganzen Post eingeguckt, sondern nur den Kommentaren und die Antworten zu diesem einen Kommentar.
Ah, stimmt, du hast recht.
Ah, hier steht noch mehr drin.
Maus-Performance. Maus-Performance, ja es hat immer noch Input-Lack, wie Sau.
Ja, Connection Quality Optimizations.
Ein paar gescheite Surfer wären mal was.
Das ist mir egal.
Dass das überhaupt noch ein Ding ist, ist der Witz, ne?
Weil man auch auf seinem PC ein Spiel startet und dann nichts anderes mitmacht.
Performance Tuning ist immer gut, Keyboard Bind ist auch okay, UI Improvements ist aber auch bitter nötig, die Menüs sind grausam.
FOF, ja FOF dürfte ruhig noch ein bisschen höher sein.
Ist mir wurscht.
Achso, nee, ist mir nicht wurscht. Das stimmt, das ist richtig nervig gewesen, dass du die Namen von manchen Spielern oder generell den Tag oben, das rote, siehst.
Obwohl du sie eigentlich nicht sehen solltest.
Oh mein Gott, Nummern für Sense.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt alles so, es sollte selbstverständlich sein, manche Sachen.
Aber nichts zu der Cheat-Problematik, oder? Nichts.
Nichts.
Auf Cheats reagieren sie anscheinend gar nicht.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns als Abschließung ein paar Steam-Bewertungen an.
Ja.
Der ist gut hier natürlich.
Empfohlen. Den installieren funktioniert.
Ah, da hat er recht.
Hackers, Hackers.
Ja, das habe ich mich auch schon gefragt.
Ich habe da prinzipiell nichts dagegen, aber wenn man sich an einem historischen Szenario orientiert, dann waren in der Wehrmacht jetzt wenig schwarze Frauen an der Front.
Wow, bitte noch größer machen, Steam.
Ja gut, es wird halt ein bisschen geflamet, das ist halt so. Easy Flame.
So Jungs, ich würde sagen, jetzt spielen wir noch ein bisschen Battlefield.
Spielen wir noch eine Runde Battlefield. Wer mitspielen will, auf diesen Server hier.
Und sobald genug Leute auf dem Server sind, kann es losgehen.
Also, so wie man das erwartet hätte.
Ich lock mich jetzt erstmal ein. Lock in.
Und jetzt Play Match.
Oh, es sind schon fünf Leute auf dem Server, das ging aber schnell.
Na hoffentlich kriege ich noch Platz.
So, wir haben eine Admin-Konsole starten, auch was sehr schönes.
Einfach eine Admin-Konsole starten auf dem zweiten Rechner.
Und sobald einer cheatet, wird er gebannt. Easy, so einfach kann es sein.
Keine 3 Milliarden Reports oder sowas. Einfach, und wenn er cheatet, wird er gebannt.
Fertig ist. So, stellen wir das Game mal um.
Battlefield 3.
Origin, wie wäre es mit Game starten? Hallo?
Es ist erlaubt Origin, dass du das Game startest.
Origin ist auch so eine Kackplattform. Ich habe jetzt gerade auf starten gedrückt.
Jetzt steht unten drin, Waiting for Game to exit. Du hast das Game noch gar nicht gestartet.
Was ist das hier?
Lull.
Jetzt habe ich es nochmal abgeschossen über den Task Manager.
Jetzt ist immer noch Waiting Game to exit.
Okay, quitten wir Origin nochmal.
Join Server.
Ja, Punkbuster spackt manchmal rum.
Das hatte ich auch schon öfters mal.
Da muss man einfach den Service nochmal stoppen und wieder starten und dann geht das.
Joining Server.
Ich glaube jetzt startet das Game.
Oder?
Ja, Game startet.
Nice.
Und vor allem das Game startet, kackt nicht ab.
Das Game kackt nicht ab.
Obwohl man Fenster switcht.
Das ist fast nicht zu glauben.
Jebaited, outdated, overrated.
Dass Server einfach mal instant voll ist.
Die Gamer regeln das im Gegnerteam.
Werden die neu, dass die Gamer regelt.
Jetzt erstmal wieder an das Game gewöhnen.
Erstmal wieder an das Game gewöhnen.
Hallo, spring runter.
Das spielt sich so anders als COD.
Spielt sich komplett anders.
Ich muss mal hören, da kommt nämlich klar einer.
Komm her.
Fuck, ich wollte mich nicht hinstellen.
Ja, das ist kein 64-Spann-Server.
Da habe ich schwer drauf gelegt.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Rush-Server mit guten Settings.
Und nicht irgendwie so eine Kacke da.
Was geht denn mit dem ab?
Heckt.
Ich höre da ein Panzer, wir bräuchten ein paar Engineers.
Darf man nachschauen, klar.
Solange du in mein Team kommst, darfst du nachschauen.
Du weißt ja, ich kann nicht moveen.
Falls du im anderen Team landen solltest.
Panzer, verpiss dich.
Geh weg.
Vor links, vor links.
Reds, please.
Ja, ich switche dich dann.
Der Law-Skill-Gamer.
Move dich, move dich, move dich.
Ich muss echt mal wieder reinkommen, das ist so schwer.
Habt ihr gesehen, ich habe immer noch den Sprung-Reflex.
Kopf raus.
Ich habe immer noch den Sprung-Reflex von Kott.
BF3 wird noch...
Ja, BF3 hat noch genug Spieler.
Man findet Server, man findet Games, ein sich kein Problem.
Hinter mir.
Die Sau.
Level noch die Pistols hoch.
Nope.
Need healing, need healing.
Wo ist dann der Fatal?
Need healing.
Die Gamer regelt da hinten aber ganz schön.
Das finde ich...
Das finde ich nicht gut, dass die Gamer so regelt.
NA aim.
Leute.
Sag mal. Bitte, lass mich doch mal was treffen. Was ist denn das hier?
Schretz dich, schretz dich, schretz dich Kollege, schretz dich.
Was? Ah, super.
Fatal, da ist er.
Jetzt geht es ab. Wir müssen jetzt aufräumen.
BZ2 können wir demnächst auch mal wieder spielen.
Spitten bravo.
Erst mal wieder reinkommen in das Game.
Ihr könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen, wie extrem die Umgewöhnung ist.
Zwischen World War 2, COD und das hier.
Das kann man, das kann man, das kann man nicht begreifen, wenn man es nicht selbst spielt.
Was spielst du neben Overwatch momentan so für ein paar Singleplayer Games?
Kopf raus.
Sag mal, warum kriegen wir gerade so mega auf den Sack?
Oh, das ist so schlecht, da sehe ich nichts.
Was? Wie hat der sich denn hier reingestellt?
Hast du Hellplate gespielt? Ja, habe ich. Komplett durch.
Hab ich.
Hat sie voll ver...
Fuck, da steht er im Container.
Die Runde ist durch. Ja, die Runde ist durch. Nächste Runde wollen wir ordentlich spielen.
Das ist immer schwierig, so eine Runde noch zwischendrin.
Einfach noch die Fresse gekriegt.
Da, jetzt geht es los.
Ja, boah, geil. Fand ich auch gut.
Fand ich auch gut.
Allerdings überhaupt nichts für irgendwelche Let's Plays, finde ich.
Auch wenn YouTube wieder voll damit gewesen ist.
Das ist einfach ein Game, was nur wirkt, wenn man das alleine vom Rechner spielt.
Das lief doch gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Bester Ping hier. Sechser. Sechser Ping.
Sechser Ping. Geht ab.
Welche Map kommt jetzt? Entweder kommt jetzt noch mal Bazaar.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, es kommt noch mal Bazaar, bloß die Seiten geswitcht.
Ja.
Das heißt, jetzt müssen wir attacken. Attack, attack, attack.
Rennen.
Äh, ich muss übrigens, soll ich FPS einplanten?
Dann machen wir das bald.
Act. Act. Oh, Let's Plays, Let's Plays.
Moment, was war denn das für eine Granate? Ich hab die drei Stunden angeguckt.
Ich hab die Granate drei Stunden angeguckt, es ist nichts passiert und dann explodiert sie.
Bazaar Gameplay wieder. Bazaar Gameplay vom Feinsten.
Bazaar Gameplay vom Feinsten.
Let's Plays.
Ich glaub, das müssen wir anders machen.
Let's Plays. Heute? Jetzt? Hallo?
Fuck, ey, warum kippt der so schnell um?
Die drücken aber hart.
Next.
Die leben, die leben noch.
Der FPG Typ nervt mich.
Let's Plays, Let's Plays, wir sind fast dran an A.
Alter, das Game, das ist mal Action hier. Eins muss wir gleich rüber.
Fuck, das geht so ab, das Game. Ich hab keine Munition mehr.
Das geht so krass ab, Battlefield. Warum geht ein Game, was so alt ist, immer noch mehr ab als andere aktuelle Games?
Das gibt's doch nicht. Aber ey Leute, M320 ist schon low. Ist echt low.
Das gehört sich net. Smoke ja, aber nicht hier, nicht Granaten.
Das wird schlau. Go, go jetzt.
Da müssen Granaten reingespammt werden.
Jetzt aber.
Ich muss gucken, dass von hinten nichts kommt.
Alter.
Was, was, was macht der da oben? Wie kommt der da hin?
Der macht's richtig. Der macht's richtig einfach drauf halten, was das Zeug hält.
Das geht so ab, das Game. Warum geht das Game mehr ab als neuere Games? Verstehe das nicht.
Red's Train, der Red's Train läuft.
Moment, fuck, rechts ist einer. Wo ist er? Ich seh ihn nicht.
Rein da, rein da, rein da.
Wer hat Hex? Wer hat Hex, Leute? Sobald einer Hex hat, gibt's hier Instant Ban.
Ich hab jetzt noch keinen mit Hex gesehen. Ich hab keine. Wie man offensichtlich sieht.
Ich recke nur die Leute grad, die Sau. Ich bin Hacker, sagt er.
Muss ich mir speichern.
Willst du mich verarschen oder was? Schreck sie halt einfach, so wie ich das gehört.
Fuck.
Knapp.
Ich kann auch nichts dafür, dass ich die Gegner grad so owne. Was soll ich denn machen?
Guckt einen schimmern rechts.
Aber 28.3 geht schon ab, oder? Geht schon ab, geht schon ab. High Octane Gameplay. Red's please.
Gibt keinen Red's. Max kickt ihn bitte. Soll ich mich selber kicken, oder was?
Ich kick mich gleich selber. Was war das?
Er trollt eh nur, da meint es nicht ernst. Jetzt ist es einfach nur troll.
Warum sollte er auf den Server kommen und dann sowas schreiben? Achtung, um die Bande, um die Bande.
Auch von hinten auf der Straße, da muss ich hin. Fuck, wäre ich mal stehen geblieben.
Gibt es hier eigentlich keine Red's?
Dach, ei. Leute, passt auf von hinten. Der Panzer macht das, Pants Man.
Warum ist das Spiel so geil? Warum kriegen die das nicht mehr hin? Sowas in der Richtung.
Bitte erklärt mir, dass noch mal da ist.
Wie geil, wie geil. Das ist spannend, wenn er so weiter nervt. Von hinten, von hinten, von hinten.
Da kann ich leider nicht vorretzen. Das packe ich nicht.
Haben wir noch ein paar Gegner hier? Voll weggeklatscht.
Ich sehe nichts.
Darf ich jetzt vielleicht wieder mit Farbe spielen? Bitte mit Farbe jetzt.
Ja, Farbe hat wieder Farbe. Nice Game.
THX Spiel.
Haha. In your face, Granate.
Was hat mich da getroffen?
Rekt. Au. 35, das kann ich doch sehen lassen.
Der Demigel, den werde ich jetzt mal raushauen, der nervt mich.
Wobei, ich glaube, das sackt einfach nur, kann das sein?
Ja, ich glaube, das sackt einfach nur. Dann soll er flamen. Dann soll er flamen. Ist okay.
Alter Max hätte 35.0 gemacht. Ja, stimmt. Ich gebe es zu.
Gryptoker fragt, was denkst du wird der nächste heiße Scheiß bei der Grafik von Spielen? 4K? Nee. Ich glaube, oder ich hoffe ehrlich gesagt, ich bin der Ansicht, 4K ist jetzt, das wird in Zukunft auch immer mehr zunehmen, aber worüber ich mich wirklich freuen würde, ist HDR.
Wenn man die Mainstream Verbreitung findet, HDR Inhalte, HDR Spiele quasi und HDR Bildschirme. Das fände ich geil. VR ist zuges abgefahren, wird es ein paar geile Sachen geben, auch in Zukunft wird es eher parallel existieren.
Ich hoffe, HDR. Was ist HDR? Also, ich weiß nicht, ob es, ob das, also bei Foto steht es glaube ich für High Dynamic Range. Ich glaube, da steht es bei Bildschirme auch.
Also sprich, du hast einen größeren Farbumfang, bzw. der Kontrast sieht dann auch oftmals besser aus, weil schwarzer ist oftmals schwarzer und roter ist roter.
HDR. Wer einmal einen HDR-Trainer-Film, was auch immer, geguckt hat auf einem, Moment, will keiner in den Panzer rein? Auf einem ordentlichen HDR-Fernseher, der wird wissen, wie geil das aussieht.
Das Beste ist das Beste, wirklich. Der Panzmann ist am Start, fährt gegen die Wände. Wo kommt der jetzt her?
Der will mich, der will mich stingsen hier. Ich habe es genau gesehen. Der wollte mich, der wollte mich zifieren.
Was? Warum hat das nicht getroffen? Adamil Gelfer. Na, da kann das ja nichts werden. Hallo Panzer. Hä?
Gerade so dumm oder was? Jetzt aber. Was haben die auch noch gelegt? Fuck.
Links ist einer. Links sind mehrere. Weg. Wieder ist nicht Druck. Dahinten steht ein LV rum. Einfach mal so, weil es geht.
Panzer-Action.
Mein Zauber hat mich gekickt von zu vielen Teamkills.
Darf ich jetzt wieder joinen? Dabei bin ich gerade abgegangen. Was machen meine Team-Mates denn auch in diesem Haus drin?
Geil. Ich konekte schon wieder. Das ist glaube ich kein Permabann. Das musst du dann erst 2-3 Mal machen oder so.
Oh ne, jetzt bin ich Attacker. Ne, ne, ne, ne. Moment, ich muss mich moveen. Sorry Leute, ich muss mich moveen.
Ich will schon in meinem Team von eben bleiben. Ich werde jetzt den mit den schlechtesten Stats nehmen und mit mir tauschen.
Das ist Miguel. Der wird sich aber freuen. Ne, das ist nicht Miguel.
Ok, ich bin Defender. Ich hoffe der Zauber hat jetzt keine Scheiße gebaut.
Ich glaube der Zauber hat jetzt unberechtigt ge-switched.
Geht schon gleich gut los. Geht gleich gut los hier.
Zu B rüber. Ne, ich fahre in die falsche Richtung. Ich fahre gerade rückwärts, was ziemlich hängen geblieben ist ehrlich gesagt.
Au, ich habe nichts mehr zum retten. Echte Männer sterben wie Panzer.
Ja man kann auch mit IRC in den Twitch Chat, geht seit Ewigkeiten. Geht wirklich schon fast immer.
Ich hole euch Leute, ich hole euch. Hier fliegen ja die Fetzen ey.
Oh Leute, na danke. Ey der Miguel geht mir vor krass auf den Keks. Aber der ist schlecht, deswegen darf er drinnen bleiben.
Aber das ist bestimmt Getrolle, das muss Getrolle sein. Panzer. Aber der trollt gut. Findest du Battlefield 3 ist gut gealtert? Ja das ist nach wie vor ultra geiles Game.
Also wirkt es nach wie vor. Übertrieben geiles Game.
Der trollt jetzt vom Swim. Ja ich glaube auch, dass der trollt. Panzer, Panzer, Panzer, Panzer. Okay Leute, hier geht es schon rein. Ja das ist Troll, das ist Troll Action.
Ja gut, jebaited hier, Miguel. Ich habe das ernst genommen. Ist mich gut jebaited.
Jebaited, overrated, outdated.
Also ich spiele ja hier Beatport, ich spiele ja sogar nur auf Low. Das Spiel sieht immer noch gut aus.
Also wenn man sich überlegt, Battlefield 3 ist von 2011. Das ist 6 Jahre alt. Das Spiel ist immer noch übertrieben geil.
Das sieht besser aus als das neue Cod. Das stimmt. Es spielt sich viel energischer ist glaube ich das richtige Wort dafür.
Das ist das was mir auch bei den letzten Battlefields so ein bisschen abging. Ich mag dieses, also was mir an Battlefield 3 halt gefallen hat war dieses später, also ich muss jetzt ein bisschen auswischen.
Sie haben ja danach angefangen so mit ihrem Battlefield, only in Battlefield, bla bla bla bla. Das hatte Battlefield 3 überhaupt nicht nötig. Das hatte durchgängig.
Durchgängig so diese, ja man hat so durchgängig diese Erfahrung gehabt so in Battlefield 3. Das was sie danach versucht haben die Leute immer zu verkaufen.
Ja sehe ich auch so, Battlefield 3 haben sie danach nicht getoppt. Und Battlefield 4 kam zu schnell. Das hat auch ein bisschen dazu geführt, dass Battlefield jetzt halt nicht mehr so angesagt ist wie das.
Battlefield 3 war aber auch so die Hochzeit. Letzte Konsolengeneration. Okay go go. Volle Pulle durch.
Bad Company 2 war auch geil. Bad Company 2, Battlefield 3 nie erreicht. Nie erreicht.
Moment der Typ, wo will der hin? Der will mich zifieren der Typ. Ich lass mich aber nicht zifieren.
Jetzt geht mir der mal ab.
Treff nichts mehr, fuck. Hinterher, hinterher. Volle Pulle, gib Gas. Wir holen jetzt den Panzer ein. Panzerverfolgungsjagd.
Weiter. Panzerverfolgungsjagd. Panzerverfolgungsjagd, gib Gas. Warum kommst du da nicht drüber Panzer?
NA Driving.
Ich hab keinen Smok. Treffer, ich hab keinen Smok.
Hau.
She baited. Outdated.
Aber wenn der Miguel weiter nervt, welchen trotzdem. Trotzdem wann. Ziemlich was kicken erstmal. Fuck.
Achtung.
Sag mal sterben please. Gibt's nicht. Jetzt aber.
Nice. Weiter geht's. Das hat er sich anders vorgestellt der gute. Von hinten kommt gleich der nächste Panzer.
War noch dahinten oder.
Hat's auch fast gilt sind jetzt noch ein bisschen eingeworstet.
Ich.
Ja ich hab einen h connectivity Abo REMP appeared
Wo ist der Tank, der müsste doch jetzt hier gleich kommen.
Ich glaube bei uns ist schon ungefähr das gleiche wie bei anderen
Tank gleicht alles in ein eigenes Gerät.
Fuck.
Na wie viel ist das denn hier?
Perfekt.
Easy.
Easy life.
Okay.
Oh, Panzerfahren ist anstrengend.
Na, die Leute, die Leute joinen schon wieder rein.
Vorhin, vorhin hat uns das andere Team geohnt.
Das kommt halt manchmal vor.
Es ist in der, bleib doch nicht stehen.
Es ist eher so, dass meistens die besseren Leute gegen mich haben.
Meistens.
Ich bin schon immer froh, wenn es ein paar gute gibt.
So wie hier der Nereo zum Beispiel oder der Fatal Error.
Zu uns ist was.
Ich kann da jetzt alleine nicht so vor, wir sind ganz alleine hier vorne.
Fuck.
Dacht ich kann jetzt legen.
Lege Hände.
Auf der Box.
Was fand ich, der mir gelaufen hat, ja okay, dann ist es gut, dass du gekickt hast, pass.
Ich bin übrigens wieder als Medic gesportet, ich noob.
Ja, mach das, hat richtig so gute Idee.
Wobei man den Auto Balance aber nicht so aggressiv einstellen darf, also nicht, dass der quasi
nach der Runde, äh, sorry, dass der während der Runde alle zwei Minuten da die Leute komplett
durchschwürfelt, den muss man, man darf es nicht so übertreiben.
Und man sollte Gruppen zusammen behalten, wenn es geht.
Cool Mikkel, danke.
Krak Island Rush ist geil, Krak Island ist eine der weniger beliebten Rushmaps in Battlefield
3 bei mir, aber ist gut, was ich absolut nicht abkann ist Firestorm.
Wie lange ich noch spiele, keine Ahnung, ah, die mag ich auch nicht so richtig, die Map.
Na Firestorm ist Mist, komm, fahr mal mit der Panzer, fahr mal mit der Panzer, wobei hier
werden wir wahrscheinlich vor den Chats und Helis gerecht, klar.
Achtung Jungs, Achtung, skillshot, skillshot, skillshot, oh, oh, und da andere Panzer,
da andere Panzer, warum fährt er nicht weiter, ich treffe nichts, darf ich heute noch mal
was treffen, nope, treffen verboten, treffen denied, jetzt aber, was, das hat er nicht
getroffen, da fahren wir jetzt voll von der Seite rein, den fahren wir jetzt voll von
der Seite rein, BÄÄÄM, tja Panzer du checkst nicht wo ich stehe oder, oh nee, Kälge
klauen, letzte Sachen haben wir getroffen, Beatport, was, was, hast du was von dem Drachenlord
mitbekommen, falls ja, falls ja was, nee, also ich weiß wer das ist, aber der Kälge
ist überhaupt nicht, ah, ah, oh, die springen über uns ab, die wollen über uns abspringen
und ziffieren.
Hat sie echt schön
Wie viele Panzer gibt es ja eigentlich
Fuck
Der Typ ist weg oder?
Wat?
Fuck
Fuck, ich muss weg
Von wo kommt das von da vorne?
Au
Du darfst ruhig schneller fliegen
Jetzt fahren wir von hinten rein
Voll in den Arsch kriegt er jetzt
Voll in den Arsch
Bäm
Panzerfahren macht so Bock in dem Game
Vor allem wenn man gut Copilot hat
Oah
Rett please!
Oh fuck!
Knapp!
Aber der andere ist auch down!
Get fucked!
Ja, da hast du recht!
Oh fuck!
Get fucked!
Ja, da hast du recht!
Richtig get fucked!
Das Game ist immer noch geil!
Ja!
Levo...
Das Game ist richtig gut!
Die haben viel zu...
Das ärgert mich jedes Mal, wenn ich darüber nachdenke!
Die haben einfach viel zu viel...
Viel zu früh Battlefield...
Äh...
Battlefield 4 rausgebracht!
Ich muss...
Überall...
Haben wir da Spawn beaken oder sowas?
Auf A?
Oh fuck!
Was wird denn hier gegen...? Oh fuck!
RPG und Inf!
Irgendwie viele Gegner sind da bitte schon, das sind ja 3 Milliarden
Achtung, Skill Shot
Ich würde mal sagen, die Runde haben wir im Sack
Und jetzt sehe ich noch etwas ganz unvorhergesehenes passiert
So war es zum Beispiel
Ja, Connor, ich bin halt schon alt
Dann kommt ein neuer Fashion Haul
Muss ich mal den Friseur zu überreden
Der kommt dann, wenn auch die Schminktipps kommen
Ich habe eine M-Tar
Battlefield 3 spielen noch relativ viele Leute
Scubakito
Im Durchschnitt so um die 4000 Leute am Tag
Also immer wenn ich so, wenn ich gucke, BFStats
Ja, da Fabian hat kein Bock mehr auf YouTube, kann ich auch verstehen
Dem gehen die Leute auf den Sack, sowohl die Leute, die quasi Videos konsumieren als auch die Leute, die Videos machen
Da hat er recht, kann ich verstehen
Moment, warum müssen wir nochmal defenden? Will ich nochmal defenden?
Ich habe eigentlich keinen Bock drauf
War das das Auto-Balance-Plugin?
Nee, dann war das das Standard-Auto-Balance-Plugin
Was halt schon haltmäßig dabei ist, wenn die eine Seite zu wenig Spieler hat
Defense Caspian Border ist so eines der Sachen, die ich am wenigsten war
Hallo, ruf dich
Oh, die ist bewegend los
Was?
Ich bin dumm
Erst werfe ich eine Granate ans Auto, weil ich es in die Luft sprengen will
Und danach überlege ich mir, man könnte das Auto ja klauen
Max, das war eine super, super tolle Idee gerade
Ganz tolle Idee, war das
Das war eine super, super tolle Idee
Das war eine super, super tolle Idee gerade, ganz tolle Idee, war das
Wo ist der Kack-Chat?
Hier, hier
Chat nicht trifft
Fuck, ich bin kein Medic
Medic, ich steig aus
Fuck, ich bin kein Medic, Medic, ich steig aus
Ich mach Meat Shield
Was ne Action in dem Game
Warum ist das Game so geil
Warum ist das Game so gut und die anderen Battles viel zu scheiße
Please explain DICE
BeatBot, ne mach ich nicht
Ich arbeite nicht bei meinem ersten Armored Gamer
Gewechselt hab ich aber nicht so viel
DICE, bitte wieder ein gutes Battlefield machen
Blitz, blitz gutes Battlefield
Achtung, wie aus dem Bild
Nein, noch nicht
Wie aus dem Bild, nein, noch nicht
Ich weiß nicht, von wo mich hierher, von woher mich hier gerade was trifft
Kommt ein Panzer
Oah, vereimt
Echt
Oah
Ja, ich find auch Patrick, die müssen nicht viel am Gameplay machen
Das muss weiterhin, das muss die richtige Mischung aus, ja aus, was hat's ausgemacht
Man muss was können, aber das muss jetzt auch kein CSGO Aim technisch sein oder so
Aber Battlefield 3 hat viel dazugehört, dass man das Game gut kann
Nicht rein aimen
Dann hätt ich mit meinem Xbox Scheibenwischer aimen, wäre eh abgekackt
Also damals auf der 360
Ach, der Skillshot
Wat, von wo
Ja Scheiben, kennste nicht, Scheibenwischer aim
Ich werde es dir gleich mal demonstrieren, was Scheibenwischer aim ist
Das ist Scheibenwischer aim
Du willst flanken?
Der will flanken, ich glaub's dann, flankerino will er machen
Ah
Ah, an jeder Ecke
Man sieht ja auch, in Defense muss man gar keine großartig 3, 3 Milliarden Kills machen
Man muss die wichtigen Kills machen
Das finde ich ist auch was, was Battlefield 3 ausgemacht hat
Wo man, fuck, fuck, fuck, warum, warum ich wollte, ich bin, das war jetzt fail
Ich wollte eigentlich wiederbeleben, aber ich hab festgestellt, ich bin ja gar kein Medic
Was würdest du kaufen, Freezing oder G-Zone, gar nichts
Also wenn es der Monitor hat, schön und gut, aber ich würde mir keinen Monitor gezielt dafür aussuchen
Denn, FPS größer all
Ich dachte das Ding ist voll, weil ich keine Lebensanzeige gekriegt hab
Ich würde mir gar nichts davon beinkaufen, ich würde gucken, dass ich ordentlich viele FPS erreiche
Das ist das wichtigste
Es gibt nichts wichtigeres als FPS
Und wenn du viele FPS hast, brauchst du auch gar kein G-Zone oder Freezing oder so
Das schreibt was
Kennt ihr noch die Zeiten, wo die Leute mit dem Chat, wo die Leute den Chat, kennt ihr das noch
Wo die Leute den Chat gewastet haben
Den Chat gewastet haben, um da oben drauf zu fliegen
Und dann von da oben irgendwelche krassen 830km Sniper Kills zu machen
Findest du es scheiße, dass man Battlefield 1 und noch Server von DICE kaufen kann
Solange es die Möglichkeit gibt, finde ich gut
Die Möglichkeiten sind halt ziemlich beschränkt
Ich glaube es geht noch nicht mal mehr Sniper Limit mittlerweile
Ich glaube es geht nicht mal mehr ein ordentliches Sniper Limit auf den Battlefield 1 oder 1
Dann sagen sie ja, Admin Abuse und das wäre ja überhaupt nicht so wie das Spiel gedacht ist
Admin Abuse ist wie das Spiel gedacht, das ist doch ganz einfach
Man sucht sich einfach seine 3-4 Server, auf denen man gut klarkommt, die ein gutes Regelset haben
Wo man weiß, dass keine spasten Admins am Start sind, keine spasten Mitspieler am Start sind
Und spielt eben auf diesen 3-4 Servern
Das ist doch ganz einfach
Ich sehe das Problem an sich überhaupt nicht
Die sollen den Admins wieder ordentliche Möglichkeiten geben
So was wie Sniper Limit ist must have
Ohne Sniper Limit kannst du keinen ordentlichen Rush Server spielen
Wenn du da so paar geile krasse Möchtegern-Dings hier face Leute am Start hast
Die meinen sie müssten mit 8 Reagants auf dem Berg liegen und snipen
Was willst du denn da machen?
SSD-Ladezeiten-FTW
Jetzt wird erstmal alles gebashed
Warum habe ich denn keinen Zoom?
Erklär mir mal please, warum habe ich keinen Zoom?
Warum habe ich keinen Zoom bei dem Scheißding?
Moment, was?
Alter, ich glaube es hat wieder das überlebt hat
Fuck, ich muss weg hier
Nein, nein, nein, nein, lass den nicht in LLV klauen, lass den nicht in LLV klauen
Fuck
Das war schlecht
Den Fehler muss ich jetzt wieder ausbügeln
Weil ich ihn zerstöre
Wir haben uns den LLV klauen lassen, wie der letzte Kackknob
Mach den LLV kaputt
Aber der Typ hat keinen Bock zu fahren, der bleibt einfach stehen
Ich habe unseren LLV wieder
Aber auf meinem Server gibt es keine DLCs, weil viele Leute Probleme haben mit den DLCs oder die DLCs nicht haben und sowas
Auffall an
Ich lege
Okay, er legt schon
Au, was?
Patrick, Back to Kackn habe ich auch rausgenommen, weil irgendwie Leute Probleme hatten sich zu connecten damit
Du kannst das auch mal aus der Config rausnehmen
Wenn du am Bearbeiten von der Config bist, dass es beim Neustart nicht mehr geladen wird
Au
Suppression
Das ist schrecklich, Kollege
Damit hättest du nicht gerechnet
Schreck mich nicht so
Ich habe aber übrigens keine Munition mehr, das fällt mir gerade so auf
Das ist ziemlich doof
Um nicht zu sagen, das sackt Balls
Flank Action
Straße Flank Reno
Braucht man Munition
Hallo, jetzt hat er das nicht aufgenommen
Was war das jetzt mit der Pistole
Wir haben ja vorhin in Call of Duty schon geübt
Der Pazifist, es gibt ein paar Server, die noch voll sind
Es gibt genug Server eigentlich, du findest fast alles was du suchst
Solange du keine DLC Maps suchst
DLC Maps gibt es nicht mehr viele
Server mit DLC Maps
Alter, fällt auf mich wiederzubeleben
Ich geh ab, die zwei
Jetzt holen wir uns jetzt
Wie geil das wäre, wenn sie noch mal so ein Game wie Battlefield 3 rausbringen würden
Also jetzt nicht, ich meine damit kein Battlefield 3 Remake oder so was
Sondern ein ordentliches Game, wo man ordentlich spielen muss
Wo es nicht darum geht, jetzt irgendwie die krassesten Kills zu machen und sonst nichts zu reißen die Runde
Aber einfach wirklich überlegt sinnvoll spielen und wo man auch was von hat, wenn man das Spiel ein bisschen geübt hat
Nice Position
Wo kommen die denn her?
Da drüben sind die Scheiße
Ich wusste nicht, dass er schon so weit oben ist
Ja, deploy spammen muss sein
Deploy spammen muss sein und M16 muss auch sein
Deploy spammen, wichtigste Beste
Fuck, in your face
Wir kommen nicht wirklich rein, haben wir hier nicht noch einen LV als Attacker?
Dann sollten wir uns mal schnappen
Ich bilde mir zumindest ein, wir haben hier normalerweise einen LV
Nice Position
Einfach alles bashen was da rein will jetzt
Jetzt kommen sie raus
Ich blicke da immer durch
Nice, nice Plant
Richtig gut gemacht
Die haben die Waffen nie am Griff in Battlefield 3, obwohl man den Griff dran hat
Da hatten sie wahrscheinlich keinen Bock, das noch irgendwie zu animieren
Battlefield 3 ist besser als Battlefield 4, immer noch für dich
Die ganze geladene Action aus dem schnellen Wiederbeleben, diese bessere Bullet Penetration
Man kann ja in Battlefield 3, wenn man gut steht, sprayt man fünf Gegner weg, weil die Kugeln einfach durchfliegen
Guckt euch das mal an
Das ist permanent, wo sie uns noch erzählt haben für Battlefield 1
Hier ist permanent so
Warum haben die Gegner einen LV, haben die schon immer einen LV, die haben unseren LV geklaut
Das bringt gar nichts, wenn ich da überhaupt nicht bewege
Wir sollen mal unseren Medic Train umstellen
Oder geht der jetzt kaputt?
Ok, ist kaputt
Wir haben ihnen das jetzt gelegt
Leg mir bitte etwas, leg mir den Minipack
Hallo?
Rollen?
Ich brauche einen Minipack
Das ist ein Sparda hier, oder?
Rein da, rein da
Ich lese gleich, was du oben geschrieben hast
Was hast du da oben geschrieben?
Das Internet der Dinge, was?
Ja, das Internet der Dinge Video
Was geht hier ab?
Jetzt kommt unser LV noch dran
Was haben wir, wenn unser LV da was reinballert?
Das könnten die noch mal kriegen
Ja, der LV regnet das
Ja, gut, was soll ich da zu sagen?
Internet der Dinge
Das war knapp, ja, das war richtig knapp
Aber das war lustig, ne? Wir haben den LV
Am Anfang habe ich den abgegeben, danach habe ich den Video geklaut
Und danach jetzt noch mal
Also bloß, dass die eben andere gemacht haben gerade
Aber das war, LV hat Regeln gewechselt
Die 10 dümmsten Security Fails
Ja, das wäre ein schönes Clickbait Titel
Ein schöner Clickbait Titel für ein Video
Dann lasse ich mich mal über die ganzen Hexor-Dings aus hier, der Beta
Ich finde, Hardline hat nicht so reingehauen
Vorhin war der Pantsman am Start, sind abgegangen, was war das für eine Map?
Caspian Border und
Also bei dem einen gingen wir übelst ab
So, wichtig hier, Scheiß auf A
Scheiß komplett auf A
Da müssen so viele, wie es geht, bei B rein, dass man das ordentlich Defenden kann
Weil sonst haben wir gleich im Rücken irgendwelche Gegner
Ich retz, ich retz, ich retz
Wo sind denn gerade alle?
Was?
Was war das für ein Death grade, kann mir das mal einer erklären?
Versteh ich net
Kannst du mir mal bitte erklären
Die Gegner machen es clever, die kommen schon mal nicht vorne rum
Zwanz gebashed, Zwanz gebashed, Zwanz gebashed
Granate ist gegen den Kopf von einem Typ geflogen
Retzen, ganz wichtig retzen
Das meine ich, durch Gegner durchschießen, das macht so geil in dem Game
Das ist so nice
Wir nehmen uns aber gut in die Zange
Scheiße, Scheiße, das war zu viel
So mach was richtig
Die Glasflaschen haben mich umgehauen, ok
Jetzt muss ich gar net
Warum ist der nicht umgefallen?
Leute ihr müsst jetzt rein pushen
Lasst euch nicht bashen
Jetzt vorbei, jetzt bin weg
Jetzt kriegen wir das noch nicht mehr
Was? Ah in der Ecke liegt er
Zu spät
Ne, Krone ist Prime
Das soll ich doch nicht so bashen mal
Ich hab jetzt ein bisschen Schiss hier zu stehen, ich bin ganz alleine
Hallo, hallo L.A.V
Warum ist der nicht umgefallen?
Der Subbutton weiß nicht, irgendwann kommt er bestimmt mal
Ich werde auf dem Channel Spiele zeigen, an denen ich Spaß habe
Ich will nicht, dass ich da wieder das Gefühl habe, ich müsste jetzt irgendwas machen
Ich kann mich leider nicht wieder beleben, ich versuche es aber das geht nicht
Und vielleicht mache ich mal irgendwann ein Subbutton
Aber das setzt mich dann immer so unter Druck, wisst ihr, oder habe ich immer so das Gefühl ich müsste jetzt irgendwas machen
Der L.A.V. Typ, der macht es denn schlecht
Hallo, springen
Oh oh, ich hab Schiss
Ich hoffe der L.A.V. sieht mich nicht
Warum sind unsere Leute auf der Seite?
Das ist verkehrte Welt, wir sind Defender, wir müssen auf die Seite
Das ist falsche Seitenverteilung
Jetzt bitte, jetzt bitte
Cuts FPS Emotes, oh ja, das machen wir
Das waren mal Cuts Emotes
Streck den Kopf raus, alter, streck den Kopf raus
Streck den Kopf raus
Erwischt
Ich gucke ob der wiederbelebt wird, dann wird er gehauen
Bald der wiederbelebt wird, dann wird er gebashed
Heckt
Darf ich treffen? Ja?
Voll der L.A.V. in die Seite reingefahren
Komm, ich spawn jetzt auch mal als Engineer
Wir haben schon so viele Engineers
Man braucht hier immer, oh oh, oh nein, ich snoop
Warum bin ich jetzt doch als Engineer gespawned
Pfeffer
Ich sehe nichts mehr
Ich spring hier mal rauf, ich muss mal rundherüber gucken
Was schaust du für sehr eine Gerade eigentlich, eigentlich gerade nichts aktiv
Die GEMA regelt, die GEMA regelt ja
Guck mal, die außen uns mit zwei Leuten weniger, drei Leute
Gerade gucke ich keines her
Weil ich mir Preacher Staffel 2 mal angucken wollte erst, fand ich ganz gut
Hab auch keine Zeit gehabt
Mr. Robot 2 wollte ich mir auch nochmal angucken
Wobei ich das nicht auf der hohen Prioritätsliste habe ehrlich gesagt
Weil ich die zweite Hälfte von Staffel 1 schon nicht gut fand
Was sacke ich jetzt eigentlich gerade so
Hast du mal ein Anime geschaut? Ja den ein oder anderen
Also nicht so viele, also ich weiß andere konsumieren da
Quasi fünf Serien die Woche gefühlt
Kommt her, ich will euch bashen
Wo überrennen die uns denn gerade so
Hier können wir überhaupt nicht ran, wir sollten uns darauf konzentrieren B zu halten
Scheiß drauf, B halten ist das Wichtige
Wobei kriegen wir es, kriegen wir es doch
Nice, nice, nice
Rektorino
Grenade
Ich hab null, null Prozent
Wie siehts mit Mädels aus, es gibt aktuell kein Grill FPS
Falls deine Frage darauf hinabzieht
Die sind aber alle kaputt gerade hier, alle down
Und es ist das beschissenste Spawn Location überhaupt
Was, ich war doch schon um 5 Ecken
Es war blöd, dass wir jetzt das andere Mkomm auch verloren haben
Kommt Gogo, B kriegen wir vielleicht noch
Nice, wir haben es in Schere
So ich warte jetzt bis es nachladen muss und dann gehen wir hier ins Haus
Und der ist an mir vorbei, nein, ich wollte gerade messern von hinten
Ich hinterher rennen und dann messern
Und ich wusste, ah da kommt noch einer hinterher
Fuck
Wo war der denn jetzt, ich dachte der ist links, aber ist er nicht
Das neue Twitch Design geht gar nicht, warum
Warum
Was sackt am neuen Twitch Design
3 Milliarden Gegner
Oh ne, keine Chance
Ich bin aber so langsam aber sicher auch ganz schön kaputt, wie lange bin ich denn schon on
Oh wieder 4 Stunden
Ja fast 4 Stunden
3,5 Stunden fast 4 Stunden
Fallback Pliat, Fallback
Oh Mann, warum erwischen die mich gerade so von der Seite die ganze Zeit
Ich bin ich doch sonst immer der Flanker und bash zu alle
Gibt es doch nicht
Wenn man den Flanker flankt, das ist eigentlich, das geht doch gar nicht
Die Scheibe ist auch mit ein bisschen Lack explodiert
Und Tschüss
Was trifft mich da
Das ist ein Pre-Fire, Pre-Fire, ich wusste der kommt um die Ecke
Ich wusste er kommt um die Ecke
Was trifft mich denn hier
Auch Meat Shield
Immerhin
Da ist noch einer
Wenn der Flanker flankt, da läuft man den normalen Weg und da ist was dran
So genau habe ich dann nie drüber nachgedacht
Lass mich doch einfach mal 2 Sekunden laufen
Was
Instant Dawn
So sieht es aus
Sag mal
Spawn tot, Spawn tot, ist ja gut jetzt
Ist ja gut
Jetzt aber, jetzt wird es direkt
Ist ja gut dann
Ich sehe nichts
Oh, oh, oh, da rennen 3 Milliarden Leute rein
Das ist Milano
Revive und Pray
Echt jetzt
Ist wirklich so
Revive besteh nicht hier rein
Siehst du weil wir jetzt zu sehr auf A rum gehampelt sind haben sie B geklickt
Ich muss vor, ich muss vor, ich muss vor
Was hältst du vor Minecraft ESL
Spawn tot, Spawn tot, Spawn tot
Alter
Ich würde ja gerne mal in irgendeine Stelle wo ich nicht Spawn tot bin
Ich fürchte fast da kommen wir dann mal rein
Spawn tot, Spawn tot
Ich würde jetzt immerhin auf den NRW geschweißt
Oh, Suppression Metal
Sowas hatte ich glaube ich lange nicht mehr
So Leute, GG
Super Games
Aber
Mir reicht's für heute
Ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen
Und wahrscheinlich sehen wir uns morgen, ist ja immerhin Feiertag
Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss
Und bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss
Und bis zum nächsten Mal